morning good morning welcome to this
meeting of baby bird rooster council's
planning committee it's the first
virtual meeting to be conducted by baby
district council
so please do bear with us we've done
some training on it we've done quite a
bit of homework
members have so hopefully it will go
through reasonably well with this
morning but please do bear with us
before I commence the meetin properly ie
on your behalf would like to pay our
respects to Nick Wrigley who recently
passed away earlier this month he was a
passed Baber counselor who's served on
the council for 16 years from 2003 to
2009 teen when I've served with him in
all that time and so as many others on
the committee he's been on the planning
committee cries a lot
and it was sudden and sad his parson so
the chairman of baby district councillor
counselor John Ward will be paying
tribute and respects to him at the next
full council meeting so I would no leave
that to him but I felt we should just
note that thank you may I first of all
remind you of some of the domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
that's muted in this case that you do
not interrupt other speakers members are
reminded that they should not have
alternative communication lines open
ohyeah other Skype chats and that if you
are contacted by a third party during
the application you should bring this to
the legal advisors attention which will
come to are introduced later
if that if you are that if you are
attending the meetin to speak and
persistently interrupt the meet and you
may be asked to leave a member if a
member of the committee is conducted by
a third party during the meet and then
they must bring this to my attention as
soon as possible if members do lose
connection to the meetin that they must
contact the members support office
Amanda Spears as soon as possible and
you all now have that number I would
like to remind everyone present that
this meetin will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewings the hold of the meetin
will be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt agent if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to be and recorded by entering
this weaken as a speaker you are also
consenting to be and recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcast and and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meet and
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded that's the formalities
members I'd like to introduce the
officers present we have Stephen Stroud
and he's official titles to seat
projects and delivery manager as you
refer to you as chief planning officer
for today Stephen Jo Hobbs is the case
planning officer it will introduce the
case ENT prey is the planning lawyer for
paper district counsel and OSHA refer
teams legal and rubber Carmichael who's
brought all this together as the
government officer and I'll refer to him
as Officer Carmichael
now can I move to the agenda please
I will ask the government officer to a
roll call for members present over to
you
Thank You chair just check so I'll now
call out your name if you could just say
good morning or present or anything
along those lines it's a councillor
Aires
good morning counselor Barrett yes good
morning counselor beer present
councillor Busby oh yeah I'm here
councillor Hinton okay Jameson McLaren
good morning counselor Osborne president
correct castle Owen councillor Parker
present and councillor plum and I
believe I've just seen the Hardacre has
just joined as well yeah thank you right
so I would just ask my colleague Mandy
again if you wouldn't mind seeing if you
could contact counselor John Hinton
regarding that in the meantime I'll just
get a ask mr. Duprey if we carry on
again until we get to the actual
formality part of the application if
that's acceptable yes mr. Carmichael I'd
react not yes I can't I don't think we
can't see councillor Hinton in the list
of attendees but I mean if this was a
normal committee meeting we would we
would get on with doing the formalities
and minutes etc if he arrived in time
for the first item that we quite lawful
so yes I agree we probably proceed on
that basis thank you
yes I concur with all that he wasn't on
my list that I went through just before
we started
I've answered so let's hope we can
contact him right members will carry on
to receive declarations of interest by
members do we have any gang we're going
to ask the members will call their names
out and your arms that you do or you
don't
okay thank you counselor is none Barrett
none castle appear none Kessler Busby
run counselor Jameson man Castle McLaren
none castle Osborne nine cows lowing
none councillor Parker none Chancellor
plumb John and councillor Hardaker I
don't know if I dukes I'm here on behalf
of the ward regarded a planning
application we still have to ask on that
census because even if you are the world
met but you could still have an interest
in an application beyond cheering beyond
thank you cancer I'll just read out that
other statement with regard to the
application before us today
so as members have previously heard one
of the applications before at the
committee that would took place last
year I would remind members that they
should approach this application with an
open mind and if any member does not
feel that they can do this I would
advise them not to take part in the
meeting I just want to make that clear
chair before we begin yeah our endorse
that so are there any to declare again
you need to do the roll call with
councillor Ayers so I'm sorry
men may I butt in sure just I think I
would do this here just Rob
we're going to that in but as an officer
as your legal advisor I must just say
briefly as I did wear the slightly
different application came to us over a
year ago that I know mr. Levitt one of
these speakers professionally through
the local legal profession because he's
the rest of the judge of the dipswitch
Crown Court and I don't go to court very
often these days but in might a previous
job on the other side of the county I
knew him well as well when he was a
barrister and later as a judge but that
is that sort of thing crops up quite
often there's no there is no obstacle to
me caramels your legal advisor bhun or
just ought to be noted thank you I think
when we headed at the faith or plan
enlighten and we were all present and
you said the same things there so yes I
think that's all quite acceptable okay
Rob over to you okay for just that
second point then so councillor Ayers no
I'm fine
councillor Barrett no counselor
none Castle Busby yep same for me
kasa Hinton you know Paula geez oh is
that just hits enjoy interest
so I'm just checking the list there
chair so councillor Jamieson none
Kathryn McLaren no Castle Osborn no Owen
none Kessler Parker none and has a plum
thank you Jeff
thank you right we can move on to the
next pint to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 11th of March are
there any points regarding accuracy of
the minutes
they've been sent round can I have a
proposer please can I propose that we
accept the minutes Thank You chair thank
you very much and a seconder yes I
second that
thank you then I'll ask the officer
again Rob to take a roll call vote which
we have to do in this case so again
overdue Rob thank you Jim
so if you could please respond with four
against or abstain so council heirs for
councillor Barrett for Castle a beer for
castle Busby well counselor Jameson for
McLaren cast I was born for Owen for
councillor Parker or and cast a plan
or let's carry chair I'd also just like
to note that I believe councillor Hinton
has joined the meeting so I if possible
chair just like to ask if there any
declarations of interest from councillor
Hinton yes councilman do have any
interest in patients of interest to
declare council Hinton can you hear us
oh so we can get these capsules council
hands on muted muted on mutinous I know
[Music]
Chancellor Hinton are you still muted if
you've got a cross through the
microphone then that means we can't hear
you and we still can't hear you chair
legal I wonder if I want out could we
could we try good man dethrone him or
something can we can we just see this
yeah he obviously is here on our
attendance list all right well while
you're sorting that out I'll go back to
the minutes if that's okay Robin just to
read a little bit on that right the vote
was for approval of the minutes of the
March and the minister meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practical opportunity members okay thank
you I'll just carry on I'll stop before
we get to the schedule of applications
item file you've to receive notification
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petitions scheme cancel the
Karma I'm sorry officer Carmichael can
you comment none received chair thank
you site inspections officers are there
any site inspection requests
that's Steven yeah and not at this point
chair there was a query from counseling
that I'm aware of yesterday but I think
that's been covered now if she's able to
confirm okay so you have none to request
members are there any site inspection
requests that you wish to put forward
I'll take that as a no rather than go
all through the roll call because you
would light up if you wanted to comment
and you haven't thank you very much
so I'll now go back to you Robert have
we got a connection with counselor John
Hinton not at present chair I believe my
colleague is working on it well we'll
take a five minute little German too so
if we can get him connected okay
mr. chairman I think I met with you how
can you hear me yes I can hear you John
the computer was fighting back this
morning well we I can hear you loud and
clear there's just a couple opinions I
need to ask you and you'll just need to
say yes or no to a counselor Hinton one
is do you have any interest by members
no thank you and it's legal it's legal
here and good morning counselor Hinton
see into pray here for you and chair and
the you may not have heard if he looks
and having trouble getting in the
counselor hint and I can't recall
whether you were one of the counselors
present in April last year when we had a
similar application on the same site
well if you're not if and the the
chairman has asked all members to has
really I read it out for so yes thank
you this was to all members and notice
put John st. John as we previously heard
one of the applications before I would
remind members that they should not
approach this applicant that they should
this application with an open mind if
any member does not feel that they can
do this I would oppose them not to take
part in the meeting so you've got to say
yes or no to that
yes what did you have an open mind I
have an open mind yes can I don't
believe that I was at the last meeting
that's easier thank you very much
against look into them right so well
they're all still present so we'll carry
on
we're now on item 6a the schedule of
planning applications will be taken in
the following order
DC's stroke 18 straight at zero two zero
one zero and DC stroke one eight strokes
zero two four one two lend on the east
side of Brantford road known as rowing
waste Broten Suffolk
I will now invoke the case officer Joe
hopes to introduce the application to
the committee case offices presents the
application okay it's over to you Joe
Thank You chair I'll just share my
screen with everyone so you can see the
presentation bear with you one moment
while that loads up
okay could I just get confirmation chair
that you can see that presentation okay
no I can't okay
of Kasich has all other members got it
if you haven't just say no fine lovely
thank you Jeff so the application before
members today is an application for
49:12
in the village of sportin she's just
showing being highlighted on the slide
there the application as 49 grounds for
full application it includes 17
affordable dwellings which is the full
35 percent requirement open space access
from the rainway footpaths and there are
a number of bungalows houses and a few
flats which I will show you through the
plans as we go through the application
now just to point out at this point
there are two application numbers before
you and they are two identical duplicate
applications members have seen one of
the applications before we presented 18
4 - 0 2 0 1 0 last April but now we are
presenting both applications and seeking
a resolution on both applications today
I will go through the case history and
why we are where we are in a short while
so just to give some more context on the
site location here we have the site
highlighted in blue village of sportin
hips which to the east the a14 and in
Brantford to the north and just to give
the site and a little bit more detail
here is the site location plan and and
just to highlight in the core strategies
count core strategy sportin is
identified within the Ipswich fringe but
also a hinterland village just to show
the in detail location we've got the B
11 13 or Lorraine way it's also
identified as Brantford Road in the
application documents but it is Lorraine
way and to the south the site we have
lower streets burst or Lane and just to
give some context we've got the wild man
public house at that Junction there such
as to show you where it is
in the application history as I just
advised members resolved last April on
one of the applications that previous
application was for 54 dwellings I will
show a plan of that previous development
in a short while members resolved
refused the application on heritage
grounds as shown in page 51 of our
agenda documents today and there was
also discussion around flood risk the
committee meeting officers advised that
there were some flood risk issues that
we were still discussing with the
Environment Agency and whilst
Environment Agency had no objection
unfortunately the development that
members saw for the sequential test this
meant that in fact there was a second
reason for refusal regarding flood risk
the applicants asked if they could
resolve this matter on flood risk so we
could narrow down the reasons for
refusal and officers considered this
request under our core strategy policy 1
we are required to work positively and
proactively with developers to try and
resolve issues and so we did agree to
allow the applicants to try and resolve
the flooding issue to resolve the flood
versus you the site layout plan needed
to be amended to in effect remove the
development from the high-risk flood
zone the applicants at the same time
also sought to try and address the
heritage issue which I'll show you in
the plan shortly the revised layout has
then led to the fact that members have
not seen this revised plan and is now
leading to us needing to reconsider the
applications as in effect members
haven't resolved on the current plans on
the application so today we're asking
members to consider the revised plans
for both applications and to make a
resolution on those so just to show the
slides of this is the previous layout
plan for 54 dwellings currently on the
slide and if I just play the animation
it transitions through to the new
layouts now members you'll see it will
just transition a few times and then
stop the new layout which it will end on
shows that the
has been pulled back both from the
Heritage listed buildings so the that
the top of the slide here and also
removing their development from the
flood zone which is where I'm just
sharing with my mouse now could you
spare me one second I will just make the
mouse a little bit more visible there we
go so the data has been pulled back from
this area here which is the harvest
flood sign and this open space has been
created here
here's pulling back the development
slightly sittest to show the previous
development again and the current layout
so just to give a little bit of other
context on the site and just to mention
the tabled papers before we get too far
into the application and there have been
264 objections on this application and
one neutral comments so just to point
that out to members and just to say on
this table papers which members have
received there is one additional consul
to comment from a farm to health officer
and the matters they raised can be
covered by conditions there's one an
additional condition suggested in that
tabled paper to do with the sewage
treatment plant and site just making
sure we have the noise level information
for that and there are a couple of minor
clarifications to the report to note as
well on that tabled paper just three
wants the constraints now of the site
and here is the site shown or outlined
in orange and we have the key
constraints we have the flood zone two
and three along the river Gipping which
is just in the center of that blue area
and we have a number of listed buildings
I will show us another slide in a second
in a little bit more detail because
they're quite small on this slide and
just to show the area in brown that has
just appeared is the existing
development boundary in sportin and this
site sits outside of that development
boundary here is a slide of the listed
buildings which has been provided with
the application I'm just going to run
through them each and just show the
grading of the buildings so we have a
sportin hall which is a grade 2 listed
building the tithe barn and the barn is
Broughton Hall those two barns which are
both great to mill the mill and mill
house in sportin both
to the Church of All Saints which is a
gray two-star mr. building and then once
a Ford Church place grade to lower house
and stores grade two to two or low
street grade to the web and public house
great - and walnut cottage great team
and then the final constraints is to
point out to members the light green
area which is across the whole of the
site here is special landscape area and
we have public rights of way along the
giving river so now just to show photos
of the site we've got the site location
plan and the arrow pointing where we are
looking so here we are looking South
found the B 1113 the application site is
on the left it's been just a note on the
right hand side there is another site
which is subject to a planning
application being considered at the
moment I will share that another slide
in a later in the presentation and here
we are looking across the site towards
the church and support and hold and the
two barns that are listed and as to
further photos slightly back and he can
see the electricity lines which are run
over the site but are clearly separate
from the developable area you can just
see from the site layout plan here
there's no demand proposed under those
electricity lines when here we are
looking towards the development existing
housing along Lorraine way that's a
slightly closer view of the group of
listed buildings taken from the south
the site towards Broughton Hall and just
looking towards the the existing
dwellings on lower Street and it's the
closer look here hi it here just from
hovering there laser now is the junction
the Wildman public house and we've got
the development going along the rheine
way and lower street here and just look
at those houses right next to the site
on lower street just swinging around the
south of the site
and a long view looking north on the
site and that's the view from the access
to the tithe barn at the community shop
and just to point out here this is where
one of the proposed footpaths from the
site will come through to connect the
site to low street and the last few
photos just looking north along the
rheine way and just to point out to the
right-hand side here where I'm just
hovering the laser now this is the
location of the second footpaths
connecting the development to Lorraine
way which comes out through this gap
here between the two houses this
vegetation scribbly vegetation would be
clear to provide that footpath link and
then we've just got a couple of slides
that have submitted from the
longer-range landscape views slides from
the applicants the supporting
documentation and here we're just
looking down the B 1113 so we're looking
south and it just shows the public
extent of the site and then the bottom
slide it shows the visibility of the
site from the Gipping Valley Riverwalk
so public footpath 22 and you can see
from that red line across the top of the
plan there the extent of the site so you
would see glimpsed views the development
towards the left-hand side of the site
here and then again just fuse across the
public footpath and from further north
just showing the glimpsed views that you
will see from a wider range so just to
go through the site layout plan in
detail and just pull out some of the
particular features the access here
would be proposed here with the right
dedicated right-hand turning lane on the
B 1113 it's one access in and then
internal roads I will have a slide
shortly to show you it's roser to be
adopted just to draw out the public
footpaths we have footpaths being
created within environments sorry we
have a footpath which is being created
through this area here and coming out of
the community barn
tithe barn on lower street here and
that's the second footpath coming out on
the rain way it should show
photos of here the electricity lines
running through the development which as
I mentioned earlier are clear from the
proposed development other features to
note is we have a tree with its tree
preservation order on site that is
supposed to be retained and protected
here and just to generally pull out the
other details of this revised proposal
we have a slightly formal landscaped
area here and intentionally designed to
try and reduce the impact and the hedges
assets which I will go through in a
moment and gallery' of landscape ground
here and open space will be available
for future residents and residents of
sporting here's an indicative layout of
landscaping plan it is on the previous
layout of development so please actually
do ignore the actual dwellings but it
just gives sorry there's been slight
amendments the dwellings but this gives
an indication of the layout of the
landscaping in this film space and over
here and it also shows where the surface
water storage feature would be on the
site just to the north for hovering now
here's a model of the proposed
development it's taken from his
collection listed buildings so the
community barn and barns there whose
Warren Hall so it's just shown
development looking towards the B 1113
along the back of the slide there just
to draw out the building heights the
applicant has responded to concerns
initially raising the application and
proposed that there were single-story
dwellings just where this brown shape
has appeared here to try and respond and
respect the scale of existing
development along lower streets and try
and reduce the impact on close neighbors
the remainder of the development is
two-story and here's this the plan to
show the external works of the materials
to be used on say the hard landscaping
but in particular wants drawing
attention to the roads that would be
adopted which are just shown in yellow
here highlighted in yellow so these are
the roads that the applicant is
proposing to be adopted which the higher
authority have
accepted and raised an objection to now
I just want to run through some typical
elevations of the proposed built form
the red arrow just shows where the plot
is that I'm referring to so this is at
the entrance the site plot 45 and just
the other side of the entrance not to an
example of one of the bungalows to the
south the site and share the use of
different types of materials on the site
includes a black weather-boarding to add
a bit of design variation and good
design quality and also here is one the
dwellings to the east of the site which
uses white weather-boarding
just draw attention to one of the larger
buildings on site which is shown here
this is post s6 and residential
affordable flaps it's a slightly large
building but officers consider that as
it overlooks the open space the scale is
acceptable and would not contravene any
design standards and just to share the
development which is visible through the
existing vegetation as you travel south
down the B 1113 this is the one of the
buildings closest to the road so just to
identify the affordable housing we've
sought to ensure the affordable housing
is just species throughout the
development there's no larger group than
12 affordable was in one location
because we want to try to make sure that
was an integration to the wide
development and not just located in one
area so these dots the blue dot show for
rent units and the purple shared
ownership units just to make a
comparison to show that the development
would be 10 you're blind we've ensured
that the design detailing is on the
market dwellings is very similar to the
affordable dwellings also there's some
variations but we want to make sure that
we'll see the design quality is as good
on the affordable dwellings as it is the
market dwellings okay so that's the end
of the plans and now i'm swatching run
through the key issues and just go
through a couple of the issues in a bit
more detail just to explain them to
members so the key issues as obstacies
and the application sizes obviously
outside boundaries there is a landscape
impact as detailed in the report are
they only moderate to adverse across the
small area of the site as surrounding
footpaths and in the wider landscape
context not significant overall
landscape harm but it is important to
note there is some moderate at first
harm to some areas and when being the
development local housing need the
applicants have submitted some
information but as detailed in the
report they have not submitted a full
local housing needs assessment however
on balance there is information from the
local community about the housing needs
and so we consider that on balance there
is sufficient information and it's not
an efficiently lacking to America reason
for refusal on this application so we
just note that the information provided
there could be better but it is
sufficient and heritage impact which is
one of the key issues I will go through
a little bit more detail shortly on the
precise nature of the heritage impact
but it is has been identified by offices
but if the heritage officer and myself
as a medium level of less than
substantial harm which I've seen gages
paragraph 196 of the MPP f2r
requires to consider whether the public
benefits of the scheme outweigh that
harm we will come to that conclusion
later the benefits of the scheme this
site is considered to be in a good
location and more sustainable location
than some other sites within the
district obviously it's in close
proximity to Ipswich the a14 another key
benefit is the provision of housing 49
dwellings and it's a full complement of
35% affordable housing and there is a
net gain for biodiversity on the site
with the proposed measures that being
put in that would be secured by
condition
also we do have to have regard for the
NPP F and this site would whip to help
the council boost its supply of housing
which is a requirement under paragraph
59 of the MBTA F and it's also a sites
which could be considered to be a small
to medium sized site which are
encouraged in the MPP F and paragraph 68
to help with the supply of your housing
as it can often be delivered in a
quicker manner than some of the larger
scale sites so there disappear
considerations to bear in mind to look
at Heritage in particular and here I've
just got a slide of the applicants
assessment of the setting of listed
buildings and I just want to show this
this is one of the key areas of
discussion that we've had the applicant
just showing their current proposed
layout 49 dwellings under here have
shown where they consider the setting
félicité buildings are so I'm just
talking over a sportin hall and where
they consider the setting is and then
there's also a wider setting of the
church which goes through the site now
officers do not necessarily agree with
this assessment the setting of a listed
building is it's difficult to really
kind of kind of perhaps throw it so
tightly as this and as you'll see in the
committee report we considered that the
functional relationship of this cluster
of listed buildings and this land are
more affected by this development then
and say this plan would say so we
considered that this proposed
development is within the setting of
these listed buildings and the line
doesn't really stop here as the best way
to describe so this development we still
consider has a medium level of less and
substantial harm even after the
revisions to pull this development back
that the applicant has made and so in
this sense the level of harm is still
the same in officers opinions as the
previous scheme for 54 dwellings that
members considered last year this is
obviously a matter of disagreement
between the applicants and officers but
officers advise is the level of harm
remains the same and although the devant
has been reduced here it doesn't reduce
that heritage harm at all than the
previous scheme
what do with that heritage harm is
obviously very important in our planning
balances them required by the hundred
and paragraph 193 of the MPP F and as I
said earlier we need to consider the
public benefits which I'll do so as I
get towards the conclusion of this
presentation now just to go to the flood
risk matter in its in more detail on the
screen now this is the previous layout
of development and the previous flood
risk assessment and the issue we had as
you'll see from the top of the slide
here we had development proposed within
flood zone 2 & 3 and we also had works
to almost re-engineer the flood zones to
make the flood zones the flood water
move into this area and collect here
both of those matters meant that the
site engaged the sequential test which
is a requirement under the MPP F to try
and find whether there would be a site
more suitable elsewhere that doesn't
involve development in those high-risk
flood zones and there are other sites
where plank Mishnah been granted but
hasn't yet started so the site failed
the sequential test and this is what
happened after members saw the
application
last time at committee so the only way
we could address this is by moving
development outside of the flood zone
which is what applicants have proposed
so this slide is just transitioning now
to the new layout so this is the new
proposed layout and as you'll see all
the development has been pulled out of
the flood zone and so there is only a
footpath being proposed for that flood
zone now and obviously some of the open
space there are preciate members must
consider that this flood zone is still
quite close to the development but we
obviously have to consider in policy
terms whether this is acceptable or not
and all of the development that would
lead to a flood risk to people or
property has been moved out of that
flood zone and so the the intentions of
our core strategy policy 15 and the NPP
F to protect people against flooding we
consider has been met now the site still
is within flood zone 2 & 3 because the
red line still goes around the site here
there is no denying that and so the site
still
required a sequential test but we don't
consider is reasonable to refuse the
application on the basis of the site
being in this close proximity to flood
zone now as all development has been
pulled out of that flood zone and the
risk to people and property has been
removed so as detailed in the committee
report we don't feel that this is a
strong reason that with its stand appeal
if the application was refused on that
basis so in floods a flood risk
assessment M of the site is that it is
on balance acceptable now in progress
terms just to draw on the emerging joint
liquor plan the plan currently has
limited weights in the making process
for a planning application but I just
wanted to show what was happening in the
surrounding area with the ALP the
application site is shown in blue and it
is not included as a potential site that
the council is looking to allocate but
over the road there is a site which is
contra be promoted by pidgin the site
application boundary is slightly larger
than this I will show you it on a
subsequent slide but then looking to
promote land opposite this application
site and then we have sites also been
proposed for Hopkins homes the south of
Brantford you just move up and also site
to the north of Brantford where
penetration has been granted already and
here we have Woolsey Grange the South
Sea and then in blue we have the
employment areas supportin and the
employment on water range as well so
just to look at the sites around the
application set a little bit more detail
and to draw on the highway impacts we
had considered with the highway
authority the other proposed
developments coming forward and this was
reported to the last committee to
members as well that a cumulative
highway assessment had been undertaken
by all the applicants in the area
I just ran through which applicants they
are so that site to the north of
Brantford 490 goings which has
permission
the site 115 dwellings which is
currently been considered an application
for envelope contains as well on land
south of Fitzgerald Road 114 dwellings
submitted by pigeon on land to the north
of bursts or Road and this application
site so all of these applications came
together to consider their community of
hari impact and a number of highway
mitigation measures were identified and
secured through planning contribution
through section 106 agreement as they
have been for the permission that has
already been granted and as it's
recommended to on this site and so this
location would in effect pay pro rata
into that section 106 pot to bring
forwards the highway improvements which
are along the B 1113 and a detailed in
the committee report oh just to bring
the application to conclusion the final
summary the members have resolved
previously on the previous layouts but
the layout has been amended to try and
address the reason for refusal and flood
risk as we have been trying to work
positively and practically with the
applicants as is identified in our core
strategy in policy one and try and
refine down reasons for refusal there
have been no changes in material last
allocation was permitted that presented
to members so by this I mean that our
five-year land supply position is stay
that's still the same that we had a
five-year land supply then and we still
have a five year land supply now the
same level of heritage harm officer's
consider was proposed in the previous
scheme as in the current scheme and all
other material considerations have
remained the same in planning terms and
so it's difficult for officers to
recommend different to the previous of
approval but obviously is for members to
consider how they wish to resolve and
how they wish to balance the matters
being presented in this application so
we have conflict with the core
strategies development is outside of the
Andrey's as inter fight under the core
strategy policy to the proposals are in
broad compliance and officers opinions
with the key policies CS 11 and CS 15 of
our development plan
C
eleven enabling development outside
hinterland villages if it meets the
criteria of that policy and CS 15 and
the criteria of sustainable development
there is a heritage impact of less a
medium land of less than sensual harm
which officers have taken to be a
serious matter when coming to the
balance in their recommendation but it's
considered the in this instance because
this site is in a good location within
the district a sustainable location it's
has good benefits of policy compliant
affordable housing and also the other
benefits office leaders generally
providing housing and equality net gain
it's considered that in this instance
that all those matters together when
balanced against the Heritage impact
that they do overcome the Heritage
impact and the public benefits of the
scheme outweigh that Heritage impact in
this instance also the infrastructure
and highways matters adequately
addressed to the satisfaction of all of
the statutory Council peas and the
Suffolk County Council infrastructure
and highway authority and all other
matters are adequately addressed as
identified in the committee report so on
balance this proposed development force
and Wellings is to consider to be a
sustainable form of development the
recommendation from officers is for
approval as it is detailed on page 45 to
46 of the agenda Thank You chair
Jerris counselor Hinton its Joe here I
can hear better I haven't heard anything
from the chair yet so what to see what's
happening hello everybody in this week
is anybody in this meeting hello
counselor Henson is he right
I heard Joe a moment ago no Hobbs okay
just confirming that you've heard the
end of my present all the way to the end
of my presentation I judge mrs. Hobbs
and and yes thank you
right okay so Mandy's going to I'll ask
my colleague Maddy to ring cut the chair
to find out about what is going on so
what I would propose just until we make
contact with the chair all the chair
comes back to the meetings we just take
a very quick adjournment until we can
reestablish contact with the chair thank
you rob mr. Carmichael
Audio Peter Thomas it
[Music]
will we be taking a break at 8 o'clock
tonight to go out and clap for the NHS
I have nothing on my screen at all
councillor McClaren I had in the
presentation down I will just put it
back up if just to check that you can
still see it I just took it down whilst
I wasn't talking I'm am I the only one
that's cut off then I just started the
presentation back up again okay I can
see that but everything else everything
else has gone okay I saw I Mary if it
appeared in the same boat as everybody I
think it's useful keeping the
presentation up because we will well I
certainly would like to read yeah work
towards it when we ask questions on that
okay yeah okay councillor Osborn it's
Claire here can I just confirm that you
can hear us now yep morning Claire yes
everything is back as it was thank you
brilliant thank you
but can you hear me now just hello yes
German oh yeah yeah just very quiet for
the moment alright I'll just write i've
got public speaking slide 46-hour can
that members hear me I don't know what
happened I didn't touch anything can are
all members bag are all members bag just
connect you here okay I'll turn this
phone off right remembers that's if you
still all hear me
does any member wish to have any points
clarified by the case of officer
canceller heirs I'll start with you but
if anybody else wants to speak perhaps
they'll type it in the chat box don't
debate at this moment is there any
points you just want the presentation
was wonderful thank you good good
no one's typed in the box so I will go
move now to public speakers
John Hinton you want to ask something
deeds yes please come up in the box but
not worry I've got you now yep the
wonders of broadband just a couple of
questions from the from the officer
concerning the report on page 18 it
don't doctors surgeries being
insufficient and then talk about two and
a half mile radius is there are two two
surgeries it doesn't say what the direct
route or sorry the actual Road route
might be to those surgeries and
certainly does nothing in the report
about anything to do with the mitigating
measures or anything like that could the
officer
elaborate a bit on that those two points
can be clarified oh yes thank you chair
yes the comment on page 18 is direct
extract from the NHS England comments on
the application and the response to your
question is that the healthcare
provision would be provided through a
SIL payment so a sill bid would be made
to then increase the capacity as the NHS
saw fit and provide that health care
obviously that's not precisely detailed
at the moment but we have no objection
from NHS England and it consider that
with still payment and they could
provide the appropriate health care
needs for those future residents okay
mr. chairman does that need adding into
the recommendations that would be the
first come back on that and the second
point that I just like clarifying at
this point is the the officer mentioned
the overall traffic plan for covering
Brantford Woolsey Grange total of about
a thousand thousand plus houses but
there's no mention within within the
report on page 19 for instance of what
is going to happen to traffic through
the actual existing street of Broughton
where we all know that there is traffic
chaos at the moment okay so Joe okay
thank you to take those points in turn
we we don't generally put the SIL
requirements in the recommendation only
the section 106 requirement it's better
and perhaps we could make a note so Hema
can take advice on that whether we could
just make a note in the minutes to make
it clear that Healthcare Group A through
SIL and on the second point the traffic
impact on the streets within sport and
that has been thoroughly considered by
the highway authority through the
application and and part of those
mitigation works that I mentioned would
improve would look to ensure that there
are no adverse impacts from this
development which is obviously all we
can consider today is whether this
development would make these listings
any worse and with the highway
improvements that identified to be
secured through section 106 and the as
detailed in recommendation the higher
authority considered that this
development would be acceptable so it
has been considered the existing Street
Network but as I say we can only
consider the impact of this development
on the existing traffic levels and not
potentially look at the existing
problems within sportin and it's a
necessarily solve those imbalances the
question thank you if I could just come
back that it talks about three
mitigating measures one of which is a
zebra crossing and I'm near the wild man
and I can't see that that he's actually
going to do much to sort out the parking
and general traffic flow problems on the
main part of the street then talks about
burst to lane lower street junction
well that's avoiding that Street
bottleneck again as well and the beagle
roundabout of course he's quite a long
way away from there from that Street as
well and traffic's got to go through
that hazard of the street before he gets
to the beagle roundabout so it hasn't
really looked at what happens between
the wild man if you like and the beagle
in terms of traffic so it must seem a
bit strange and just to come back on the
the health provision to have health
provision from Syl is a little bit of a
joke for the simple reason that we're
talking now on this particular
application of something like where my
figures I've got them here somewhere oh
yes 425 thousand pounds of silicon to 49
houses where only 32 of them will be
liable for Syl so the drain on the
overall sill pot for the for the whole
district it would be quite considerable
and I have to say that NHS England are
have shown there should we see their
limitations join this coab in 19 and the
points of clarification have been
I think you're getting more to debate
question pipes so I think we need to
move on and you can bring that up when
we get into debate to pursue that if you
so wish
members is there anybody else that
wanted them can clarify you'd like to
ask question kind of a clarification yes
yes that current slide shows the
footpath that's proposed through the
site near near to the river was there a
previous footpath through the site that
the public could access that that walk
no no the site currently isn't publicly
accessible on this side of the river but
the public right-of-way is the other
side of the river and just off this
slide great thank you
thank you any other member with points
of clarification yes please chairman
councillor McCann thank you can I speak
- yeah thank you Joe I'd like to just
clarify I did some homework on this
flooding I've never come across this in
my sort of short experience and I was
wondering about the explanation what was
a flood plain and according to the
experts where the river and the land
side of it is on the same level
considering that and we it's a very
small area I understand the head of the
Environment Agency Sir James Bevin has
said that building new homes on
floodplains should be resisted if at all
possible is that your view yes obviously
the guidance that we require to follow
is considering whether the site it
wasn't abandoned on floodplains and as
my earlier slide showed that all the
devout side of the harvest flood zones 2
& 3 it's all within flood zone 1 which
is land so even the highest mountain in
the UK is technically floods
one it's the entire abyss flood zones of
two and three which we are looking to
keep the development outside of and say
this this this development isn't within
those high-risk flood zones now with
this revised scheme and so it wouldn't
be built on the floodplain
which was shown in blue just around kind
of hovering the mouse at the moment
there's answer the question thank you
chairman thank you any other points of
clarification no thank you
then members we're going to move to
public speakers as both of the
applications are for the same site the
public speaking arrangements have been
agreed that the parish minutes okay
members any questions for you thank you
thank you okay
Thank You chairman Rothman parish
council objects to this application in
fact there are over 250 objections to
this application from Sprott and
residents
it was refused by ourselves last year
and the reason for a refusal have not
gone away we strongly believe that it
should be considered in the context of
the multitude of sites and applications
coming forward along the kipping
corridor contributing to an almost
continuous ribbon of development along
the beat rebel 1/3 the original draft
joint local plan identified four
possible sites between Sprott and
Alfred however three of these sites have
already been submitted and are at the
public consultation stage before the new
JLP has been issued another infill site
has been submitted as of this January
not included in Jos slide which will
leave a 15 meter strip of green between
the Sprott and Hopkins home site and
brantford sites if this doesn't meet the
definition of creeping coalescence we
don't know what does the existing
adopted local plan policies should take
precedence the drumdial p being some way
away from completion the NPP f
specifically warns against creeping
coalescence with the approval of bennett
homes 30 houses and Woolsey Grange 475
houses a significant chunk of the
20-year local housing need has already
been approved and greatly exceeds the
demand captured in our September 19
housing needs survey if this application
is approved taking into account those
already approved this will double the
size of the parish this application is
not needed also the application is on an
unallocated site as per the draft JLP
and outside the built-up settlement
boundary of the village there are
already enough sites allocated to
scrotum within the Draft JLP so this is
a purely speculative application we are
now working on a neighborhood plan there
will be considering suitable sites this
is unlikely to be one of them other
specifics we would like to mention
infrastructure we are concerned about
the lack of provision for infrastructure
especially in respect of health
education and travel there are no nearby
GP surgeries with space Sprott and
primary school is full a local shop is
voluntary
both the NP PF and local policies
dictate that development needs to
consider provision of infrastructure in
order to be sustainable SCC strategic
planning has called for a master plan
for the area so that the cumulative
impacts and needs can be properly
assessed we agree world life there are
proven animal corridors across Lorraine
way which connects several woodlands and
the Gipping Valley as a whole there is
not either
archive corals or ensuring the
protection of local animal species
including protected species traffic
traffic volumes along the beat rebel 1/3
are already high the assessment fails to
take into account the cumulative effects
of other planned developments in
Brantford Pinewood bells dead break
blakinola Hadley in Sudbury to which
this development would contribute we
were shocked when we learned of a
proposed no parking clear way through
the Narrows Broughton high street this
is part of a package of suggested
changes none of which we have been
consulted on even 12 months on traffic
measures need to be implemented that
calm traffic through Sprott and protect
residents not speed it up flooding each
winter the River Gipping floods to a
greater or lesser extent on to the
surrounding fields in Providence
Broughton we have had unprecedented
levels of rain this past winter and the
area around the Gipping has flooded more
than normal we can no longer regard
these events as one offs given climate
change predictions these predictions
have not been factored into the way
flood assessments are currently done
it's not just local rainfall that
contributes to flooding
it's the rainwater runoff from further
upstream where new housing developments
will funnel the water into the river
when it cannot be absorbed in the ground
given this development is close to the
river there is a real risk that this
development as well as other parts of
Sprott and could be flooded in the few
heritage something that's been mentioned
a lot the northern village boundary is
formed by a collection of listed
buildings all set within a special
landscape area this heritage rich rural
edge is treasured by the village and has
remained untouched for several hundred
years
the 2015 Babel landscape character type
report recommends development should be
on plateau farmland typically along the
a 107 won in preference to rolling
valley farmland which this is Hopkins
have attempted to consider the wider
views of setting over the grade two
buildings the whole tithe barn root barn
Church closed All Saints parish church
together with their interaction across
the site with the historic listed
buildings in the wider landscape however
we feel they have failed as the revived
lay out still completely intrudes on the
important heritage views in addition
designs do not blend in with the
existing buildings in fact the revised
layer shows the new houses to be closer
to Sprott and Hall and the root barn
than before historic England guidance
setting set out in the setting of
heritage assets makes clear that having
identified assets affected by
development and their significant it is
necessary to minimize harm this
development is the opposite and breaches
policy see n06 which states that any
development should be of appropriate
scale form citing and detailed design
the harmonized with the existing
heritage buildings and its setting and
also contrary to policy CS 15 of the
core strategy which states that any new
development should respect existing
heritage assets we do not feel that the
arguments for this development are
sufficiently compelling to ignore the
harm to heritage assets in summary the
reasons you rejected this application
last time round still stand and we ask
that you refuse this application again
thank you
councillor bill
is everyone else - yes
contact counsel appear again please if
he hasn't already done so so if we just
wait again and ask members to just mute
their microphones until we just can
reconnect with the chair thank you
can you hear me now Rob because this is
I'm not doing anything can you hear me
yeah I can hear you charge I don't have
an answer to your question now I'm
afraid oh right sorry
then the progress bar went one over six
minutes I asked you to move but
obviously couldn't hear me so I think we
have to add and edit onto other people
to speak if they want to use that time I
don't know if you managed a time at your
end at all
yes chose exactly six minutes it was but
that nine closed down at six minutes
now I'm telling Jerry Lee legal here I
saw it as being six minutes exactly as
well like like mr. Carmichael right well
then you need to tell me that in future
because mine's sure it is not that she'd
ran out of the six minutes long before
then so I've missed ignore mine I'll
rely on yours so my apologies to mrs.
Davis okay we seem to be back up and
running again members is there any
questions to the speak up Helen Davis
anybody know you can all hear me
okay thank you very much that's a chair
councillor Parker here I just type in
the pain I do have questions here can I
just answer that it certainly isn't
coming up that anyone's typed in so you
will need just to bring your attention
to me okay to open the message the chat
box on the left
possibly
I thought I'd done that that's all a lot
right
it's got smaller and everything can you
still hear me yes yes Joe yep right yes
penslar Parker Thank You chair and just
like to thank mrs. Davis as well for her
presentation was excellent and clear but
I do have one question mrs. Noakes you
mentioned that you are in the process of
forming your neighborhood plan could you
just inform us at what stage you are at
as a parish councils with naturally I
guess I can thank you
we kicked this off at the beginning of
the year we have confirmed that the area
boundary is the parish boundary and we
are now thinking about public
consultation thank you Jeff thank you
any other questions
councillor how to Helen Davis just a
quick one place was interim Mrs Davies
thanks very much I agree with Kessler
Parker an excellent presentation just
one quick question have you requested
all have received any sort of traffic
surveys from height from the highways
authorities to traffic flow no we
haven't seen anything and we would
dearly like to be able to contribute to
that okay thank you
oh yeah other questions no no one's in
the box thank thank you mrs. Devers and
then we'll move on to our next public
speaker which is an objector a Martin
Levitt you have three minutes in which
to address the committee so when you're
ready I think you can indeed chair so
just before you start can I just point
out to mr. Carmichael that I cannot see
the
for whatever reason so please if we get
to the end of the time will you then
tell me okay carry on mr. Martin thank
you very much indeed um every four
seconds that I speak one more house will
be built on that open green field site
until forty nine properties dominate and
remove the historic context and setting
of the existing cluster of the eight
related grade 2 listed heritage assets
situated along the northern village
settlement boundary those eight listed
buildings are heritage assets which date
back from the 16th century and if I may
I'll refer to mrs. Hobbs's slides
because they articulate very well the
consistent concerns expressed by the
heritage officer in 2018 2019 and 2020
nothing's changed at all slide 6 and
slide 7 show the setting and the rarity
of those eight assets within the village
because they're along the northern edge
of the brown colored settlement boundary
and the settlement of the cluster of the
eight related 16th century assets is
important because when taken together
either individually or collectively they
represent the historic and the cultural
relationship that each had with one
another and also the open space across
the development site known as cardinal
field now that open space field cannot
be divorced from the setting and the
integrity of those heritage assets or
their visual prominence and the rarity
these days of tranquillity shows the
fields open space providing a positive
contribution to the significance of the
asset setting and the ability to
appreciate them from long views if you
look at slide 27 it shows the impact and
the scale of the proposed site extending
northwards by at least a third of a
kilometer and well outside the village
settlement boundary the slide also
demonstrates how the built environment
can swamp and dominate and destroy the
long view
and the loss of vigil appreciation of
the setting of the eight buildings slide
28 shows for anonymous blocks
representing the closely associated in
grade two buildings and the slide also
shows how much closer the development
clutter is and how it actually dominates
the setting of the listed buildings
especially when you compare it with
slide 10 and that's graphically sure
along the long views of the field
towards a settlement boundary and the
listed buildings so it's overwhelmingly
apparent that the adverse impact which
this development will have all those
eighth grade two heritage assets is
substantial and cannot be underestimated
this adverse impact significantly
outweighs any benefits when assessed
against the NF PP the policy
particularly paragraph 196 and that's
why the planning committee sitting on
the 17th of April last year resolved
that substantial harm would be caused by
the development which didn't respect the
setting of those Lissa's buildings so
the level of the heritage in thank you
thank you very thank you very much mr.
Levitz I'll just there there's any
questions for you can members I'll start
with councillor Ayers
have you any questions anybody else can
tuck in the box no no questions Thank
You chairman Thank You Chancellor
Barrett sorry yes please can I just ask
mr. Levitt what his views are of the
footpath that now runs through that site
and alongside the bonds well it runs
across of the boundary edge of Sprott
and Hall and it goes right in front of
the root bar and therefore is visual
from all aspects of the buildings it's
never been there it's one that's been
purposely created as a route through
from brain way to lower Street a low
street of itself is busy and if there's
a congregation of a number of people
particularly schoolchildren I can see
and foresee the inevitable accidents
thank you
any other member wish into think there's
nothing in the box
no thank you very much then was
delivered I will now ask the protector
Roanoke arm up to speak you have three
minutes in which to address the
committee they're overdue wend already
thank you very much sir
my name is Roni German and I'm chair of
the sport and working group and charity
formed sport and neighbourhood planning
team the cumulative growth impact on
infrastructure generated by 8 housing
developments in a five-mile corridor
along the kipping valley has been
immeasurably underestimated the number
of houses proposed for sportin is
potentially three thousand three hundred
and seventy five hundred and five of
those have already been built or
approved and we currently have five
hundred and eighty-one houses in our
parish we are nearly doubled our parish
community already a housing needs survey
in 2019 identified a need for 87
additional people with another 310 plus
in Brantford one mile away already
approved this creeping coalescence and
ribbon deployment results in an
unsustainable cumulative impact on our
infrastructure heritage biodiversity
landscape and local amenities you have
seen a walk to the lowest street in the
rain' way both historic narrow roads our
village it is unsustainable policy cs7
strategic site allocation lips which
Baber friend clearly states a master
plan will be required which should
ensure the separate identity and avoid
creeping coalescence with adjacent
settlements with regard to the highways
reports of all these developments they
are flawed by inconsistent data capture
and analysis that have been
strategically engineered to support the
multitude of poorly thought through
schemes changing the beagle roundabout
and putting in two zebra crossings will
not solve the problem of 2,000 extra
homes with an average of two cars per
household forget not that we are a rural
area and people have to travel to shop
work or go to school we are a through
passage between Hadley and Ipswich the
strategic development of Hinton villages
see s11 proves this site is not
stable this site does not identify with
or offer to support the rural community
local services or facilities it is
physically an urban development in rural
setting and most shockingly a modern
site along the Gipping Valley at the
entrance to our village causing
substantial impact harm to our heritage
landscape most importantly it does not
comply with government guidance The
effect of the development and the
character and appearance of the area
will change the village character
forever and create an urbanizing effect
particularly as it is in close proximity
to lifted buildings and the open
countryside resulting a material harm
with substantial historic landscape
impact this is objectionable because the
MPP F paragraph 47 implies that this is
not a key site critical to the delivery
of the housing strategy for example like
water Grange one and two thank you very
much - thank you very much members I'll
start with sue as do you have any
questions councillor for the last
speaker no thank you any other member No
thank you very much sorry yeah cancel
abuzz speech Oh any element of the
housing leavers broughton that isn't
being met by the two developments that
are already there
no all been met
thank you any other member question no
could I just say councilor park again
check it I just jump in on that very
point then please yes because mr.
chairman made mention of the housing Lee
survey how many responses home did you
receive to the housing new survey that's
after something I haven't got my hands
on at the moment I'd have to submit that
to Jo to add to the minutes later thank
you chairman if I might just comment
there was there was you know there's
comment made of
you know I think a comment was dubious
data so it would be useful to know that
if the neighborhood playing roof or
using that themselves as a as an
argument perhaps just a comment thank
you yeah your beta point I think there
Parker anything that is submitted after
can't be added into the minutes
obviously because the minutes are a
record of the meeting if it is to be
displayed publicly online that's that's
perfectly acceptable but it would not be
any details that aren't discussed at the
meeting won't be recorded in the minutes
Thank You Jen okay cancel a bit male if
this is Helen Davis may I interrupt
because I pulled up the housing needs
survey I'm sorry you can search and I
think it's illegal here I think if mrs.
Davis is saying she's that she's now in
a position to answer of questions that
she was a few seconds ago but she's
feeling some youth I think we ought to
let her give them a find some way that's
my advice okay I will accept that Helen
would you like to answer that yeah sorry
I have to move slightly away from this
computer to another computer so I hope
you still have to hear me I can still
hear yep a total number of surveys that
were distributed for 600 the surveys
that were returned were 165 and not
completed all returned light with 435 so
27.5% of the parish responded very good
thank you for that he doesn't thank you
very much indeed thank you any other
questions
to the last speaker no thank you very
much then we'll move on I will now ask
the applicant agent to speak Chris Smith
and pull something you have six minutes
to address the committee when you're
ready thank you
hello hello if we lost you all again
cheer Milan here my colleague pull
something was due to speak first I
believe sorry I am here I thought you
you're going first Chris perhaps you
thought a date between you what have you
speak no thank you
well I'll go first they increase yes
poor fella
ok my name is Paul Sutton and I'm an
independent planning and heritage
consultant with over 40 years experience
in town playing and heritage matters
including as a principle conservation
and design officer for a local planning
authority I'm also an associate member
of the Institute of historic building
conservation I'm acting for the
applicants Hopkins homes and I have been
involved with this site since May 2017
we have listened to enacted upon
concerns expressed by members of this
committee when the early proposals for
54 dwellings were considered in April
last year the scheme now comprises 49
dwellings and the area of proposed
public open space in the vicinity of the
nearest listed buildings to the
application spot has been significantly
enlarged this would create an attractive
landscaped open space bordered by
footpaths which would also help to
preserve the key views of the adjacent
listed buildings from within the center
of the site and at the entrance to it
setting in the context of heritage
assets is to a large extent the
subjective concept it is defined in the
MPP F as the surroundings in which a
heritage asset is experienced and the
detailed assessment work I've undertaken
concludes that the impacts of the
proposals are confined to the wider or
extended settings of those listed
buildings closest to the application
site and also considered in detail the
contribution that these wider settings
make to the overall significance
both individually and collectively of
these heritage assets the conclusions
show there would be a negligible impact
on the wider setting a warm up tree
cottage and sportin Hall and a minor or
low adverse impact on the wider setting
of the
baan tithe barn and the parish church I
believe that these minor impacts on the
wider setting of these heritage assets
constitute a low level of less than
substantial harm to their overall
significance the planning officers
report notes proposals are likely to
result in a medium level of lessen
substantial harm the MPP F and historic
England guidance make no distinction
over the varying levels of less than
substantial harm but clearly within this
category harm could be approaching but
just below substantial or at the other
end of the scale approaching no harm to
their significance the MPP F is clear
about any level of less than substantial
harm to the significance of a heritage
asset should be weighed against the
public benefits of the proposals and I
believe suitable and these are set out
in paragraph C 11 8 and 11 9 under the
committee report I have concluded the
outcome of this balancing exercise is
that those public benefits are
considered to significantly outweigh the
identified level of less than
substantial harm having given
considerable importance of white and the
jamon denta fide the same conclusion in
which by your planning officer for all
of the above reasons I firmly believe
that planning permission should be
granted for the revised proposals thank
you thank you chairman my name's Chris
Smith on develop a plan of Hopkins homes
as has been outlined by your office's
since the scheme was last presented to
your committee that proposal has now
been further amended to reduce the
overall quantum of development from 54
turnings down to 49 Wellings and
increase the visual and physical
separation from the previously
identified Hera jettison assets notably
sport and Hall to the east in order to
directly address the comments previously
expressed by committee members as you
have heard we've continued to work
positively with your offices and a
confident that these proposals now
provide an attractive new development in
a wholly sustainable location delivering
17 much-needed new affordable homes
substantial areas of new public open
space and pedestrian walkways through
the site along with include carpooling
facilities for the new neighboring
community to shop
alongside these all the requested
financial contributions towards other
essential infrastructure required from
the development will be provided by the
normal SIL and section 106 procedures if
mission is forthcoming we were going to
be on site by the end of this year the
first time is being able I available for
occupation or the end next year
in summary therefore you can can confer
with your offices recommendation the
proposals represent sustainable
development and that you're able to
support the grant of planning permission
thank you and I have any questions you
may have thank you thank you very much
for that right how now sir there's any
questions I'll go to counselor as do you
have any questions you wish to ask the
applicant or agent yes yes I do okay um
I would ask that the affordable homes
and according to your report you said
that they will be equivalent or the same
sort of structures inside and can you
assure us of that and secondly with any
of them be homes for life thank you yes
if as has been mentioned by your officer
in respect to the first point the hounds
are tenured lined there for materials
detailing execution is of exactly the
same standard in turn externally as some
as on the open market homes and yes so
the affordable homes can be built to the
homes full of standard Thank You
councillor Lee Parker do have a question
yeah Thank You chair this is a question
to mr. Sutton particularly mr. Sun good
morning welcome throughout the or within
the presentation that our officer gave
at the outset there was a graph that was
shown and Joel I don't know if you can
find it it was it was to do with the the
impact upon the heritage asset and it
was the slide that I don't think we've
seen within this committee before and
I'm just curious to know you know what
what the what the scientific basis for
that there we go
I'm curious to know what the scientific
basis for that slide is because I know
our officer didn't really have a comment
to make on it but I think it's I mean
it's a crucial part I think of this
presentation and the whole basis of this
application so could you could you
explain that to us please yes I can now
counselor thank you what that slide is
an attempt to show is the wider setting
of the heritage assets in the immediate
vicinity of the site which are shown in
red and setting as I outlined in my
presentation is is a subjective concept
there is no doubt and I wouldn't argue
that the the lines themselves are etched
in stone but what they are on attempt to
do is to identify as much about the
difference between the immediate what I
would call the immediate setting which
generally speaking is taken to be the
area within the immediate vicinity of
the listed building or its curtilage is
another term and the wider setting which
normally is the area that's well outside
the curtilage of the building itself now
this is associated with views because
obviously if you can't see the heritage
asset from a particular point then it's
very hard to say that actually that
point is within the setting of a listed
building so it is based largely on a
subjective analysis of where these
buildings can be seen from within the
wider area and therefore to give some
sort of feel and steer as to their wider
setting of which the development has an
impact and what we don't argue about it
not having an impact but the impact we
both agree is less than substantial and
there is no official settings of whether
it's high level medium of lessen
substantial harm we believe it to be a
lower level of lessens substantial harm
the council's conservation officer
believes it to be a medium level of
substantial harm but that's especially
the basis for the for that drawing and
as you can see it picks up on the wider
view of the church tower from across the
site which has been designed in in the
sense that the footpath into the site
for its whole length and walking across
the public open space you would still be
able to see the church tower there were
barn and the tithe barn I hope that
helps thank you very much I'm sure it
does I had three other counselors in
blind who wishes to speak so don't think
of mr. knew yet
Cancellara Jamison thank you sir what
are you doing to make the homes carbon
neutral in line with government
requirements and also is there any
renewable energy generation on-site and
finally how are you giving a net gain to
biodiversity and also how would you
measure that three questions there for
you in terms of the first question yes
we have to use renewable technologies as
standard in our developments nowadays so
these will look at things like solar
panels measures to reduce carbon he lost
through through build built for controls
on on boilers etc all various different
mechanisms to try and achieve a carbon
reduction on the site and increase the
overall sustainability and sustainable
energy use on the site so that's that's
something that we have to do across the
board in terms of ecological and
biodiversity gains obviously as I think
you saw earlier there is a draft
landscaping strategy there and as part
of that they'd be an Associated
landscape ecology management plan which
would detail the various ecological
enhancements that we can do on-site
things like back boxes bird boxes the
day we've got additional planning on
site as sure
indicting me on here further trees in
improving hatred etc and increased
management of the other grassland all of
which will enable biodiversity and and
ecological enhancements over time
compared to the current news Thank You
councillor Busby thanks yeah you
presumably spoke with our heritage
offices did you did they suggest a
layout or design that they would be
happy with yeah Thank You councillor yes
we did have a meeting it was a little
bit frustrating because we talked about
setting at length and and didn't try and
put a line on a map but unfortunately
dr. duck wouldn't be drawn on putting a
line on a map and to a large extent that
reflects the very objective nature of
trying to assess wider setting and it
probably isn't possible to put a
distinct line on a map but what it is
possible to do I think is to try and
assess the area within which the
heritage asset is experienced which is
the definition in the MPP F and that is
largely based around places from which
you can see those buildings so yes we
have engaged
unfortunately it's probably fair to say
we agreed to disagree although we did
agree that obviously it wasn't that
level of less than substantial harm
substantial harm
thank you did you not consider that a
development of single storey buildings
would mitigate the harm on the heritage
assets we did and in fact the advice
layout shows that on two sides of the
new open spaces proposed there would be
bungalows which reflects the existing
bungalow closest to the route bomb
there's houses on one side so we have
have tried to do that and as I say there
are bungalows on two sides of the open
space although I have to say them in
terms of historic character of course
bungalows aren't a particularly dominant
feature of historic interest of the core
of the village so houses two-story
buildings tend to be a better model to
use if you are trying to blend in with
the heritage of the area Thank You
councillor Ayres we wanted to come back
yes and I'm really concerned the answer
that I had from Chris was the external
part of the buildings and I've actually
visited won't name a site of another
development whereas the affordable
housing had concrete floors but the one
the ones where they were purchased by a
buyer actually have porky can you come
in there please yeah sorry I just
targeted the the X that's the thing that
was shown on the slide but now equally
in internally the build standard will be
exactly the same if anything from
sometimes the build standard and the fit
note that we have to do for affordable
homes is enhanced because the
specification that the various
registered social landlords asked for is
above that that we would otherwise
normally provide for a market house
where essentially a potential purchaser
likes to have the options to obviously
fit out the house internally how they
would like to but so it wasn't intended
to to leave it there in any way inferior
so if anything the the affordable homes
are built to up or kid it out if you
like to a higher standard internally
than than the market ones thank you well
that was a good question and co-heirs
councillor Hinton you have a question
yeah a couple of quick questions really
firstly can you explain to us why the
major part of the road network within
the site you're proposing is unadopted
especially as most of it seems to go
near to the
audible housing and who will be
responsible for maintaining it and
secondly on slide 38 it showed some
exterior views of the affordable housing
and the market housing to show how they
blended together or had similar
appearances it appeared that the market
has his had a smaller footprint than the
affordable houses so can you explain
just what the actual accommodation size
of the affordable houses versus the
marketing houses is and that we're not
just seeing some tiny little houses
where you have a job to put the bed down
on the floor it has a salt stand up
against some wall to get it into a
bedroom very good can help yes certainly
in terms of the aspect of the house
sizes obviously all our houses now have
to look to design to the national
prescribed space standards so that sets
out those based ends that we have to
provide there in terms of the affordable
houses some of those have a slightly
larger footprint because there is a
requirement to provide X number of bed
spaces per given affordable house so
some of those might have to provide a
double bedroom rather than a single
bedroom
for this for example there for you know
the bedrooms will be slightly larger in
some of those therefore the footprint is
on some of those is slightly larger so
we that's the only reason why houses
obviously we built an awful lot of
houses and obviously you know we have to
build build them all to a suitable size
in order for a potential purchaser to be
comfortable to buy one so there's
certainly nothing under sized about
either the houses and so certainly the
affordable houses there are additional
requirements specified by both your
housing office around the registered
social landlords over bedroom sizes
which obviously we have to meet in order
to be able to to hand those over to the
to the housing associations in question
I'm sorry there was another part of the
question you asked before that yes about
a doctor adoption of the roads the roads
again the the roads as Joe is shown on
there the main spine roads to decide
both of those will
adopted by the highway authority the the
one and a few lot on the right-hand side
the the lighter yellow one is a standard
adopted tarmac Road we then lead down to
a slightly secondary if you're like in
highway engineers terms Road that goes
off and goes to the end of the site and
that serves the vast majority the
affordable housing there with an
adoptable turn and head at the end which
also serves the Anglian Water to be
adopted pump and station beyond that the
the the other hand is on the site are
served by lesser shared surface roads
there still have an adoptable standard
they simply the fact that because of the
numbers of houses that those particular
cul-de-sacs if you like serve that
they're not of a slice that the highway
Authority would normally be willing to
adopt therefore they're shown as shared
surfaced shared driveways which is in
shade joint shared ownership and again
this is the common practice throughout a
number of our developments and and they
work well and and they seem popular and
I say at the end of the day the highway
Authority are not willing to adopt those
type of roads anyone okay
I have a question from Dave both who you
want to come back again
yes cushion but having got this slide up
I think it's probably answer the
question it was the flats have any
private garden the flats don't have any
individual private garden but obviously
they all overlook a rather large area of
new public open space so they have
directly accessible probably go public
open space to utilize thank you okay
well sorry we have this problem before
with an application in cable for some
flats in terms of where people would
drive close if it's all well and good
having public space which is great but
you wouldn't want eight nine ten washing
lines full of clothes
Oh sprawled around all over the screen
area and this is part of their gotten no
they said is that there's a communal
area it's open space to the north that
you can see sort of shown in a
triangular shape there so there is areas
that can be utilized for that purpose
it's just that they are that would be a
shared area rather than you know a
private area for each individual
property but some you know so there is
there is an area that that those
requirements understand we take place
without obviously having clearly not
utilizing the public open space to do so
thank you could I just come in chair
quickly just to help clarify a point
just showing the current slide we've got
we did have this discussion with our
colleagues in strategic housing about
these proposed flats and you can just
see from the slightly shaded areas here
each flap does have a balcony space
which is covered but open where they
would be able to have perhaps a more
private area to say dry clothes and such
like so when that was discussed and also
they are quite small units one-bedroom
flats each so the amount amenity space
required potentially per resident is
smaller but they do have those covered
outdoor space balconies for each unit
thank thank you very much I don't have
any other councillors cancer Jamison you
wish to come back yeah with respect to
the affordable rental properties in only
close together but also closer to the
floodplain is there any thoughts on so
any reason or reason why they weren't
positioned why they're across the
development space
now I think in terms of the provision of
the affordable housing as you officers
diluted to that we try to make sure
they're not all in one group they are in
in two groups
registered social landlords generally
like them to be in groups for management
purposes and illegal in most kind of
purposes in terms of where those groups
are it was it was more of a design thing
that obviously is we've alluded to the
the the small units grouped together
there then have the benefit of a rather
large area of new public open space and
and quite a decent outlook you know
towards the the countryside beyond to
the north and eastern towards the river
there and also to help to frame the
development in that area so it was more
of a design thing than the actual tenure
of the building but that chose the the
locations are built forms in that area
right thank you for that cancer the
Jemison be the plan committee has over
that it's period of time can i there we
against group and all affordable homes
in one spot we like we tend to prefer
them dotted about more we don't always
get that but it's on this particular
application i kevin anybody else who's
wishing to ask the question so with that
i will assume that nobody else has got
any more questions so we will now move
on to the next speaker which is the
county council division member
councillor christa hudson to speak you
sir have six minutes to address the
Committee on County Council issues
regarding this application Thank You
Chancellor Hudson Charlie good yep good
it's good morning and good good morning
colleagues and good morning members of
the public as well what I wanted to say
mr. chairman is that I remain very much
a doubting Thomas on this application
I'd like to thank the officers for their
extensive work in this
the reasons for my being a doubting
Thomas are as follows I believe that the
development is still unsustainable there
are no changes in the material facts
from the from the last opportunity that
arose when your committee deemed it
necessary to refuse obviously I won't I
don't want to go into too much of what
has already been said mr. chairman to
waste your time but obviously being
outside the village envelope and outside
beside the jail P is a big problem I'm
very concerned about the relevant nature
of the locality what I mean by that of
course mr. Leavitt referred to various
particular settings there and IIIi think
with regard to the heritage of the area
in my opinion and indeed probably many
others opinion we would be tending to
blight to blight the area and the last
thing we all want to do is just a blight
residents enjoyment of an area I believe
that certainly environmental degradation
is very much in my mind at the moment
I'm thinking of the pollution levels
that have been taken quite widely mr.
chairman at the wild man I understand
there have been readings there and
indeed the amount of traffic that will
be generated it really seems to me that
sportin is being blighted by having far
too many houses and far too title native
places it really seems to be bombarded
it's an urban sprawl it's joining up as
mrs. Davis has said 15 meters is hardly
good space and it would seem that that's
going to be joined up into a jumbled
strip development which I don't think
he's in anyone's interest pollution as I
say from increased highway air pollution
will be exacerbated particularly through
the rat one which after I don't like to
use the expression retro mr. chairman
but I think it's so appropriate and I
know that people have referred to it
when one looks at the Main Street
through sport and I can think that a rat
run is a good description of what's gone
on there notwithstanding
the whole thing I know the traffic
custom mode classically we have had a
loss of life along that road and
probably some very near misses as well
and thinking about the people living
along there and in the village generally
it really is not a good scene I was very
very interested to hear mrs. Davis from
the Paris talking about the health
position obviously we talked about SIL
we talked about section 106 but I was
quite shocked and appalled to learn of
course that not all so money has to be
directed to any one village were you
correct me if I'm wrong here and show me
show mrs. consul but any fill or 106
money does not necessarily have to be
spent in the villages effect that it
could if they were regret and he pursued
elsewhere he shifted way away to Sudbury
or anywhere else with him within the wit
within the purview of the council so
that's no guarantee that we would get
the necessary and requisite
infrastructure it obviously other side
of the panel as I say Blythe English
village then because of his relevant
mortality heritage the settings that
we've heard about would create in my
opinion a future blot on the landscape
to quote a wall with expression but this
would be a blot on the landscape it any
only village where this is happening but
it really would be listed it seems to be
that sportin is suffering from other
development and developmental blight and
I also feel I must bring to your
attention Gary will be aware of it mr.
chairman the massive downturn
economically sadly that we're suffering
at the moment could should and could be
and probably is something that we need
to consider because the development
should not in any event be left empty
and I mean empty I'm rather tired of
healing yourself at a many empty homes
we have it runs into the hundreds it
runs into the hundreds of thousands
nationally but in our patch a lot of
empty or indeed second homes I
personally don't think that we should
give planning permission for second or
empty homes in other words there in
invest
not somewhere to live whether that's a
planning consideration that will be for
others to decide and I believe it's
essential what all members have been
able to hear this morning I know they've
been a few hiccups to hear the whole
determination of your committee and
that's a very good thing and welcome the
opportunity to be invited to give my
thoughts about it but I wanted to say it
again the financial situation not only
in sportin but in the whole of the
county is now so economically depressed
but I just wonder whether that goes to
the heart of whether these homes are
essential or will be I know that's
unknowable and there may well be sold
then there will be second homes and they
all be lived in but at the moment people
seem to me to have all on to be able to
keep a roof over their head and I'm very
very wary of allowing more development
to be where there's no guarantee that
they're going to be occupied that's what
we're trying to do I'm also very
concerned that we have the fourth
emergency service which I call broadband
and I know all new houses have to have
need Thank You counselor yeah it's
always nice to listen to you but you
have used up all your six minutes and
obliged if you stay on the line please
I'll see if there's any questions from
members for you I'll start with
councillor Ayers and anybody else from
tapping the box no questions thank you
there's nothing in the box or coming up
thank you very much then counselor
Hudson we'll move up this know of
questions for you right
members will note that from the table
papers councillor Norman had provided us
with a statement on his views his there
one of the ward members can I confirm
that all members have had the
opportunity to read this in fall you've
all
yes right I will now ask the other ward
member carolerich hard I cut to speak
you sir had ten minutes in which to
address the committee and then I'll see
if there's any questions at the end
cancel ah yes you're on carry on okay
the first thing I want to say is a these
these people aren't new movies I've been
to parish meetings and I've spoken to
them and I've seen them deal with tiny
applications and speak to them and they
do engage constructively they're not
just here I hope you got with that
impression from today that we're not
just saying no to everything point-blank
they have I think they're valuable
opinions another valuable research on
regard on this sprite site specifically
I find it very interesting that the
guidance given to councillors whether
you can only consider this development
in isolation and the air quality report
sort of in tandem with that says that
this development is of a scale that is
unlikely to compromise existing good air
quality in the area well there's two
sides the first side is as a castle of
Hudson just alluded to the air quality
is actually quite bad in the middle of
Broughton at the crossroads and the
second point is that if we're saying
that we can only consider its
development and it's only got a small
impact on traffic and a small impact on
air quality then yeah I find that very
strange because surely then if someone
wants to build five hundred houses they
just need to put in ten applications for
50 houses and each one will say it this
is only a small impact on traffic this
is only a small impact of air quality
this is only a small impact on ecology
and because we can only consider these
developments individually we we feel
bound to approve them all and that just
seems depth we have to take these
applications as a whole we have to tick
of the
texting especially when so many houses
several hundred have already being given
permission to be built we have to take
that into context not the empty fields
next door we have to assume that those
houses there or will be there and having
an influence as many other people have
mentioned their highways Suffolk
highways response may have taken into
account some of these other departments
but for their recommendation to just be
a zebra crossing or two doesn't actually
address the traffic it might make easier
to cross the road but it doesn't address
the traffic up here in Pinewood on
Shepherd Drive we have a quarter of a
million traffic movements per month
that's 10,000 a day and a weekday and we
have a zebra crossing there that I use
to get to the core and people do not
stop
they do not stop you have to wait two or
three cars to people to stop and you
know how long before a school child gets
killed because they run onto zebra
crossing and the people driving don't
stop so we have to think about these
things
and traffic its sustainability in terms
of sustainability we're told that what
counts as a sustainable development
means it's close to the leap switch and
it's close dear 14 but you can get to
Ipswich in the air 14 because the roads
are already full so you know with all
the extra development as well the roads
are going to get fuller and and what's
the mitigation around that well there is
no mitigation around that a performer's
Ebro crossing and maybe tweaking around
about this talk of hard paving the
Gipping footpath into hips which to make
that more accessible for cycling and
walkers but when is that going to happen
we don't know if and when that's going
to happen the pussy's in the
non-existent practically maybe there are
more houses that will get more buses we
don't know
council votes and also just referred to
the broadband we know that broadband
isn't that great in Sprott Manuel bar
signal isn't that great
and then there are other factors in
terms of traffic cop talk in the or
bridge so we've got all these things
that could mitigate the development and
could mitigate a traffic to cycle path
mob bosses better broadband qapla kaboom
or bridge improvements but these don't
exist and they might exist in ten years
they might exist in twenty years that
they don't exist now and we can't
approve perm notifications based on what
might happen in the future
submit a traffic that's already there go
away we have to look at what the
situation is now and the situation is
now is that it's it's a this is not
sustainable it is not sustainable
development just on the point I've just
made I'd like to second some other
points that were made earlier about my
lack of doctors surgeries the there is
only one shop it's a village shop it's
not opened that much it's run by
volunteers the pub is currently closed
there's no employment in the area yeah
so people are gonna drive they're gonna
use their cars to get around these
things are located far away when when
they want to get to them so you know a
lot of people have talked about the
heritage response but I think we do need
to look more at the traffic and the
cumulative effect of traffic and the
contribution this has and we can't hope
the cycle path ones and [ __ ] and
better broadband will appear and people
will work from home or cycle to work we
have to look at the facts and the facts
are that this isn't sustainable and
that's Newton thank you thank you very
much for that council Hardacre before I
go for questions I'm going to ask the
planning officer to clean the floor
today Steve estrella wood and the legal
Ian says whether they can comment on
what you've said about the treatment of
impact of applications can you take
these that point between the two of you
hello-hello share you go first Stephen
please right yes I can hear you
yep so essentially I think there's a
slide in Johor presentation where she
talks about how various committed
developments and uncommitted elements
have been considered by the highway
Authority and through the transport
assessment of the applicant I think in
terms of the degree to which it's
material to consider cumulative impacts
that's obviously correct and true where
you have got committed development sorry
those developed majority have permission
and they're likely to come forward and
to weigh those up against what will be
the impact from this particular
application however what I think members
need to be careful not to do is not to
engage today in the beauty contest with
other sites which as of yet have been
undetermined and looking ahead to sorts
which may or may not come forwards
through the emerging local plan or may
or may not end up being allocated in the
emerging neighbourhood plan so to an
extent yes absolutely simulation is very
important but we need to be careful to
do it appropriately and within the
sphere that we can ie in relation to
those developments which have already
been taken into account and half
Commission Thank You Ian can do on the
he's had a question now to comment from
councillor Hinton saying that fellow
consideration after recent Appeals
decision the community can do and help
well the I agree I agree with what
Stephen ascertain I think I think he's
as steam has made clear it's not an
absolute bar but you yes you do course
you have to consider every application
on its own planning merits and demerits
and the planning balance but it's not as
I think Stephens made clear we're not
saying you totally ignore the the
broader context but if this the care
needs me would be take this I I think
Stephens put it very well for meso I do
need to add much much more to that
no thank you and I think I need to
remind members as I usually have - that
we have to deal with the application
that's in
onto this now I'll go to councillor
Ayers have you got any questions at all
for councillor Hardacre the last speaker
no Thank You chairman now I haven't
looked I haven't got anyone else in the
box I did have we got counselor Busby
needing to ask a question well he's got
with that for Steve which I'll come to
after I've done pencil Hardacre and so
is there any other questions anybody
want to ask Cancellara Hardacre
no okay I would then thank you very much
scan so hard okay I will go to a
counselor Busby he wishes to ask
Stephen straight at the planning officer
a question okay yeah we used to do with
the slide that you got up slide 43 and
the keyway assessment I mean this was
put together at a certain period in time
this slide excludes and it's because it
wasn't known at the time or snow ASIS it
doesn't include the impact of a full
sugar beet site which is work we were in
towards it doesn't seem to a question
you want to ask the because that's what
perhaps would come up in debate but
what's your question to the stage you
know if the highway assessment is not up
to date how much weight can we give it
all right that's very good Steven I'm I
can't come a comment on the applicants
transport assessment Joe may be able to
to cover that point so Hobbs but
certainly I'm aware that the local
highway authority at the County Council
will be aware and will have taken into
account the full impacts of both the
sugar beet sites at full capacity
because that's already been approved and
being considered and it's a committed
development and also some Oasis bearing
in mind that I've been working very
closely with colleagues from the highway
authority for the last few years on the
reserves masses of snow aces where there
has been a need to reassess the
transport data from that so I'm
confident that the highway authority had
considered those particular developers
and all of those that would be relevant
to making the decision on this
particular app
thank you case officer Joe hops did you
want to add anything on this point yeah
as you've said the higher authority have
considered that background traffic level
from sport and she could be factory and
I did confirm that a fact with them
price this committee and they have
confirmed that they did take account of
the existing committed development when
considering the transport assessment for
this application thank you
well it just like to thank hall at
public speakers who've taken part the
small and hopefully you've managed to
keep up with it despite the one to
little difficulties we're now getting to
the debate members so I'm just going to
read this bit out as the two
applications before members are
identical the debate will cover both
applications however separate proposals
centers and votes will have to be taken
on each application
all members clear on that procedure
yeah when long as you don't say no then
okay then I will now open the item up
for debate and this is where I will
again start with alphabetical order but
if you want to tap in the box then you
can do cancel of su Aires hello hello
chair I don't know if you can hear me
yeah I did type in the box so in the
absence councillor as if I could jump in
front we stopped briefly to try and
reconnect that's correct
can you put on phone yeah sure if we
just take a very short adjournment just
to try and reenact
Thank You chair yes a couple of minutes
can you still hear me
yes yeah yes sure yeah you can hear good
good yeah okay thank you
I'll just do a rolecall to say we got
all the others Mel councillor Barrett
can tell about it
come to the Busbee I'm here sorry Peter
I know Jeff I'm here I've just took a
quick comfort break I'm here right
cancel hinton here J counselor Jamison
yeah yeah yeah canceling the Clanton
from the column yeah councillor Osborne
here counselor Owen here insula Parker
present and cancel aplomb present they
were just missing councillor Ayers
standstill
yes Charlie my colleague is contacting
her as if this moment alright I'll just
take a quick counter break
Chancellor Ayres are you back with us
now yes I'm sorry about that what
happened was um something came up to say
it got too close all my apps to do
something to do with Microsoft sorry
hello yes you're bad good yep we're all
back present okay cancel the airs you
can hear us you're muted right will now
open that up for debate
and councillor sue Ayers would you like
to start
hello yes no I don't bring in him to
debate but other members thank you thank
you
right councillor Parker Thank You chair
yeah so I'm just gonna make the point
chair if I may that obviously in in
committee when we were in chamber
generally speaking I think you refer
back to officers after you know each of
the speakers to see if they have any
comments to make and we haven't done
that this morning and I'll just
I just wanted if the officers you know
either they do or they don't if they
don't it's not a problem but I wonder if
the officers do have any comments to
make on any anything that any of the
speakers said turtle I think they were
going to interrupt me if they wanted
from what I remember but anyway yes
there's certainly a point we can put to
them to the case officer and the chief
planning officer was there anything that
you heard from the public speakers and
the two counselors that you wish to
share with us and thank you chair I'll
take that first if that's okay no I
think I personally I answered the
questions as they came up and I did did
asked us to interject at one point as
well just to make an additional comments
so from my perspective I felt that I
understood the questions but I'm sure
there'll be further matters raised
during the debate which I can respond
further - yes thank you yeah it was a
valid point I can cancel
particles normally we do it in the
chamber but Stephen strode and nothing
really great least at this point chair
only that obviously hearing the various
things that have been put forward so far
and I think having regard to Joe
Hobbes's reports they're obviously a
number of and what you might call black
collector harms or technical breaches in
terms of policy that have been
acknowledged in terms of landscape
obviously bearing in mind it's a
greenfield site and the flooding point
but obviously one of the key issues he
remembers is nothing Terra teaches is
really quite important I know this is
something that we end up stressing every
meeting but it is something that
obviously members have to bear in mind
I'm in deed attach a considerable report
importance to obviously I did notes from
from the applicants comments that they
said that any level of harm should be
weighed against the benefits which is
absolutely correct in line would be the
paragraph one ninety six test in the
MPPs
and obviously also made the comment that
the benefits were particularly
considerable knocks it out that's a
matter of judgment that members
themselves can consider and the one
point I would add is that any harm
itself must have considerable weighting
and importance attached to it and just
just because there's an agreement that
there is less than substantial harm does
not mean that it's lessening significant
or lessen important so members do need
to seriously consider those points when
they're when they're carrying out their
power imbalance shortly thank you yep
okay any other we're in debate now so
any of the member that wishes to say
anything
Thank You chair um just like to um to
kick off really perhaps and and and talk
about what I see is some of the benefits
and harm we're no strangers to planning
applications that have forth controversy
so and this is different really am real
difficult to weigh up all those there's
concerns that residents
against some of the the benefits but I
do believe I think there are some some
benefits we haven't heard very much
about really the affordable units the
single-story that's always very welcome
the it's not an isolated location it's
well connected to major sites of
employment three three miles away and it
was which and closer because of the the
proximity to the industrial areas on
that side of Ipswich and the different
you know the village of supporter has
her school and and a few few amenities
could be accessed quite easily I think
there's a benefit also with the footpath
that is introduced that allows people to
even close a passage near the those
remarkable barns that are quite a quite
a feature on the heritage aspects I III
there is quite a number of of buildings
that are noted but I think on the day of
our site inspection that we benefited
from we were struck by the view is
across the site towards the church that
have the building in the background the
weather shook a bit former sugar pig
that was the the warehouse so I'm sort
of taking that into account as well in
terms of the harm I don't think that is
that harm the harm of this development
is in any way as significant as that
harm is already apparent also the pylons
are harm as well and I think that this
this development is not as harmful as
those parts of infrastructure that are
in the on the skyline
so I would like be very interested to
hear why others have what their thoughts
are we go through the debate but I hope
they would share those with you thank
you Thank You councillor Hinton you've
got several points to raise Thank You
mr. chairman first one of course it's
the one that you spot me on earlier on
when you said it was more of a point for
the debate rather than anything else and
that was concerning silly income versus
expenditure and also the provision of
health care facilities we're looking
here at if we start off with health care
facilities at doctors surgeries up up in
Pinewood now they're a considerable
distance away from this site by Road or
whatever means you'd like to use but
less you're a crow of course it's then
it's only two kilometers but one of the
problems that we seem to have with the
NHS when it comes to these planning
applications is that we're dealing with
the NHS provider rather than the person
who actually does the job so what we end
up with is a silk contra request for a
SIL contribution for a new room on a
doctor's surgery to make it more
amenable and I believe it says in the in
the report that it talks about
extra accommodation and refurbishing and
so forth but nowhere does it mention
anything about an extra healthcare
professional to be able to cope with the
extra demand now we know that the
healthcare has been under extreme stress
just recently but and it's the same
across the whole country when it comes
to a shortage of GPS etc but we've got
to make sure that we keep these things
in balance and we're not always playing
catch-up
because I'm sure that if we looked at
the figures from the Pinewood surgeries
at the moment we would find that the
ratio of doctors to patients is higher
sorry if patients to doctors is higher
than it should be under the NHS
guidelines and the government proposals
so that's one of the first points the
other point of odds about the SIL
income we're talking about 32 houses
that are actually going to contribute
towards sill income because the
affordable don't pay cell and yet in
paragraph 10 on page 41 it talks about
nearly half a million of expenditure on
sill provisions for various things
including the provision of the
pedestrian crossings and bus stops and
going to say who knows what else nothing
there within the proposals is there to
actually mitigate the extra traffic
flows and we're talking here about
people having to get into their cars to
go anywhere because we're not going to
see pensioners who are sickly getting on
their bicycles and cycling to Pinewood
they're gonna have to go by car we've
heard from the local member and from the
county councillor that the bus service
is inadequate that's probably one a day
or something it's not very good so
unless we're going to see a massive
increase in public transport we're going
to have to see some sort of community
and community transport we can have to
see something put in there for people to
actually access facilities the
industrial sites at Ipswich have been
raised we also know that the big dirty
great big blob of a building that has
got permission that's on that sugar beet
Factory site that if you remember from
the planning application when it came
before the committee I did ask the
question is about where were the
employees going to come from for that
site and the actual applicant did say
that they would be transferred from
their existing sites elsewhere across
the region so we're not actually
creating anymore employment there so
we've then got the possibility of extra
traffic coming through Sprott and to get
to that site because unless he comes
down the a14 that's it's got to go
somewhere to get to there we know that
the traffic from Hadley into it which
causes problems at the vehicle
roundabout and because of those problems
traffic tends to nip down through
Burstall and down to the the wildman'
Junction and then cut across there to
get into it which so there is a major
problem with traffic in that area but
it's not being addressed we're just
adding to it the Woolsey Grange
development is going to create all sorts
of problems in terms of traffic traffic
flows up around that area so there's
going to be an increasing flow of
traffic away from that
so traffic's our major problem we also
heard from the parish council that there
is a 15 meter gap between proposed
developments at bombed Brantford and
it's broughton along the whatever it's
called a come from the wrote that wrote
now it's gonna have to top my head now
the road between Brantford and sportin
the MPPs specifically says that
applications that create joining up of
diverse population centers shouldn't be
allowed that there should be a distinct
gap between population centers there
should be a new lease joining up so
there's something supposed to be
happening there where we all start
talking about the cumulative effect of
all of these develops it's going to be
phenomenal on that part of the area so
unless there is really significant
impact there then we want to have
something happening there we mentioned
that I've mentioned the other doctored
roads when I asked the question from the
from the applicant about the unadopted
roads within the within the development
and the open space who is going to
maintain this open space the affordable
housing is looking out onto that open
space but are they going to pay for it
to be able to be maintained I don't
think so somebody's gonna have to afford
to pay for that to be maintained and
we're also looking at this deficit of
any form of housing need this is not a
hint in tool at a core village
it's a hinterland village and therefore
CS 11 applies to there so there should
be a detailed housing need supplied by
the developer they shouldn't be relying
on the parish to provide them with that
information parish should provide their
information if they're going to object
to an application but the developer
should be justifying his application
with a detailed housing needs survey
which hasn't been done then we've got
the the impact on the listed buildings
that can never be mitigated in any way
in my opinion there is always going to
be impact on these on those buildings
and I think if it's if it's some the
the cumulative effect of harm over
benefit is going to be taken into
consideration then I think that there
there are more negatives than there are
positives to this application and
certainly I don't think I can support it
on many grounds including CS 11 at the
MPP F but also where are the jobs thank
you thank you John you've got quite a
few questions there which I will get Joe
hubs and Stephen strode to answer at a
moment but I want to bring in Dave Busby
because he has a comment on your point
about three the National Health Service
so I'll go to Dave Busby and after you
have made your comments about that
particular point I'll get the answers to
both John and you can slip must be thank
you it's just pulling would surgeries
actually full and they're looking for
somewhere else the point about this is
just this is a small development really
and it comes at the end of a number of
larger developments the impact of multi
grange on the NHS is far more
significant than this will ever be and
they're going to have to find a solution
for that which I guess this area will
buy into I mean I there are a number of
issues that John's raised which are
based on the cumulative impacts traffic
PHS things like that and it's difficult
when you've got a small application like
this it comes at the end and the harm
has already been done the damage to
Sprott inform the traffic of snow aces
that sugarbeet site all the development
along the beach ever won three and
worzic range will be significant this
won't I don't think will be the straw
that breaks the camel's back because I
think it's already broken we need to
focus on the impact that this particular
development has of Sprott I'll come back
on that later
right thank you I would never get and if
I could come back on on Dave's point
they're very the very point that I'm
trying to make is the fact that we keep
on putting off the solutions to these
problems in the hope that something else
will come up and sort it out and it
doesn't it just gets worse and worse and
worse you've only got to look at the
traffic on the a 14 a 12 or well bridge
all these other sort of problems and it
might be a small development and
therefore it's not going to have a
significant impact on the surgery at
Pinewood unless the surgery at Pinewood
said sorry we can't cope with you you'll
have to find somewhere else then what
are they going to do Thank You
councillor Jameson is your pint on this
or is that something totally different
if you want to get your answers then
I'll come in okay thank you right I'm
now going to go to Steve and strode plan
muster and Joe hopes okay one of you
like to start yeah thank you Jerry I
think M perhaps I could start and if you
want to come in with anything else
that's okay yes certainly perhaps on the
last point you made there counselor
Hinton about existing issues and needing
to address them now I think I just need
to raise a point of kind of planning law
on that particular matter that
unfortunately we are bound to only
consider how this development can
mitigate for its own impacts and we can
consider also other schemes coming
forwards as this scheme has with other
kind of potential relevance and they've
come up with a joint solution to pay
into a pots of section 106 monies for
how many improvements but we can't
resolve the existing issues sportin such
as when the a 11 and a 14 is shut for
example and then in fact the traffic
tries to go through sport and we we
can't use this application to try and
address wider issues that perhaps
already exist and that's just a point of
planning lord I just need to raise on
that matter but then just to go through
the other matters that you raised the
doctor surgery being capacity and we we
obviously have a response from
NHS England saying that they have no
objection if they can receive the SIL
monies which they will be able to bid
for and obviously high priority for our
council to award funding to from our SIL
pot we can't obviously direct how the
NHS decides to spend that money whether
they used to extend an existing surgery
or move to a new hub of surgeries it's a
strategy for the NHS to decide
unfortunately and it's not something
that we can necessarily intervene on but
we can only comment on the fact that
this scheme contributes and the required
amount to that healthcare provision then
just to move on to the other issues of
the settlement coalescence maintaining
open space and housing needs with the
settlement coalescence and the this
application site is at some distance to
the nearest next proposed application
site which was the how to get the plan a
lot easier here we go so we've got our
applications right here I'm hovering now
and then we have the next proposed
planning application site which doesn't
have consent yet the south of brantford
here I believe some of the land in
between was put forward by developers as
a suggested site allocation but
certainly there are no current planning
applications on this land and the
emerging joint local plan doesn't look
to allocate any of this land so in the
committee report that's been written for
this application because it is that
there is a good degree of separation
still between Brantford and sportin and
that we don't consider there is
coalescence that would merit refusal of
the application on that basis I'm aware
perhaps support and their parents but
working group have raised the fact that
some of this land in between is being
put forward by the landowners at least
for the open space management for the
scheme that would be covered by the
legal agreement for the section 106 and
and the options would be a management
company if the Parish Council didn't
want to take on the land at all so there
would be a mechanism in there to ensure
that that open space is maintained
managed and open and available for use
for the future in perpetuity and lastly
the housing needs assessment obviously
like I said my
a full housing needs assessment hasn't
been done but the applicants did provide
some information from the local
community when they held their public
exhibition and asked for feedback on
what housing people felt was needed and
say we do have some evidence to meet the
requirements of policy CS 11 but as I
say we just need to advise caution that
it's not a fully compliant study and so
we just need to erase that slight
conflict with that policy there but they
have they have done some work to try and
assess that housing need you know answer
the questions Stephen did you want to
add anything no I think very much
covered everything obviously councillor
hints and will will come back if it's
not I think the only other point I would
make is that obviously are unaware that
obviously virtually every committee I
think I can recall where by Councilman
Hinton is participated obviously still
has come up as an issue and the regime
has been has been criticized but
unfortunately members we are still
charging authority and we've been very
clear that matters such as health
infrastructure will be covered by the
infrastructure levy and that's a reality
of it and I think if if members are
minded to put forward if they if they
disagree with the officer recommendation
that that should be a reason for a fusil
and I would urge extreme caution on that
point and if we were to find ourselves
in an appeal situation Thank You
councillor Jemison I've got James and
I've got you down but I'm going to take
counselor and then counselor Parker
because they both want to come back on
this particular point so councillor
Hinton Thank You mr. chairman yes
talking coming back on Joe's point about
we've got to look at the application and
not seek to use this application to cure
the ills of Broughton we're not seeking
to cure the ills of Sprott and what we
should be looking at is avoiding
contributing to the ills of Broughton
because if we're just going to make the
situation worse with every single
application then we're just as much of a
problem as as everything else is thank
you
Kent sir Parker
yeah thank you I'll be short and sweet
because actually Stephen stroud mouth
apart I will just just make the extra
point share that in the report itself
page 18 NHS England I mean yes of course
we have to take things into account but
NHS England themselves clearly have no
objection the sill is a is a ring-fenced
amount so I just at the dare lore of the
risk of being really controversial about
this I just wonder if we're trying to to
fix a problem that the NHS themselves
don't seem to have Thank You councillor
Jameson your patiently waited you can
come in yeah Thank You chair yeah I have
a lot of concerns already expressed but
Peter mentioned was the location of
these developments and the flood plains
now I know if he's on flood zone one but
if I think it's slide 42 is he still
some of these properties are still
bumping out very close to the zones two
and three and it doesn't take a lot of
extra flooding before these properties
suddenly become underwater and so
especially with climate change and the
more rain we're getting as we've seen in
other parts of the country places that
have never been flooded as suddenly and
the people learn to build this close to
someone today to a known floodplain
needs a bit of a concern okay I'll ask
the case officer to answer that one yes
thank you chair and yes it certainly was
think that we did give serious
consideration in this application
because obviously we don't want to build
homes which to be then in the future
have to deal with any flooding events
but the information we have on this
application is that the flood modelling
so the flood zones down here flood zone
2 where I'm just hovering over at the
moment with a 65% allowance for climate
change so this has been modeled on
future rainfall events the worst future
events and a climate change allowance
within there as well
so this really is the worst worst case
scenario that has been modeled and then
I think the next point I'd have to turn
members Minds too is the fact that we
have to act within planning law and I'd
have to advise you the strength of any
reason for refusal on flood risk grounds
would be quite weak because we have met
all of the policy requirements to ensure
that there is no risk of flood to people
or property within the modeled flood
zones with that climate change worst
case scenario so we have done everything
we possibly can to eliminate the risk
insofar as we can under the relevant
policy framework I think it is obviously
of concern we don't know where flooding
is is how the plan will change in the
future but we can only act on the
information that we have now and the
floods there and climate change modeling
that we have now and that's what the
applicants have done for this
application recommendation is that it is
unbalanced acceptable and it would be a
weak reason for refusal that I don't
think would stand up at appeal if we
were to refuse on flood risk grounds so
I hope that's given a bit of further
context to the flood risk situation on
the sites and where officers have got to
with that assessment
thank you Kevin Walker Mary thank you
okay and I actually was going to raise
the same thing as later councilor
Jamison did I am not satisfied really
with our contributions say to what the
environmental agency were recommending
about no building on floodplains I know
that it the requirement is probably not
there but I would have hoped the council
was taking that into consideration for
applications that are coming to them I
think the officer has commented on that
did you want to add any more Jo just
just to assure that the development path
here isn't being built on flood plain as
in flood zone two and three I think
that's the something we would assure and
that is with the worst case scenario
modeled as I as I just mentioned thank
you thank you cancel him - no
don't think your question is relevant to
this planning application I'll read it
out but I don't think dare I asked
councillor Parker if there is sufficient
PPE and if the National Health servers
have no problem with it
well I think that is totally irrelevant
to this planning application is there
any other members that wish to comment
may I just make a comment yep there's
been some discussion about housing needs
surveys and whether developers should
have embarked on their own
I must have must have made a bit of
sympathy when you look at the
participation rates of 20% of residents
taking part in in the survey that so I
guess I guess you know are they reliable
entirely when when the participation is
so so limited so I'm pleased to hear
actually that they they had a community
engagement event I did I don't think I
don't think we heard about that yet
that was so - to talk to residents and
consult with them about their
development yeah but really just my
point thank you thank you
councillor Busby thanks Jay this is
obviously going to be a balance we need
to look at the benefits and the harm
that's caused by this this particular
application
you know don't like the addition to the
traffic I don't like the threat of the
the flood zones either but I think those
points have been answered we need to
look at the things that this development
will impact it is in a special landscape
area it will impact the views of that
particular area we keep building on the
edge of these or within them and that
has got an impact on that
in terms of the the benefit side is the
really it's only the additional houses
now I hear what melody says but
sprawling has had already doubled in
size I can't believe that if he
conducted any housing needs survey that
could be a need for anymore houses
they're already in excess of 1,200 that
have been approved or up for approval so
I don't think there's a need for any
more houses in sprawl so therefore
almost if you've got anything on the
harm side it's bound to outweigh those
benefits to me
Broughton has got a distinct boundary
anything north of lower lane towards
Brantford has not been built on and this
applies to the site come forward on the
Wildman as well they are outside of the
village boundary and we have to consider
very carefully again if we approve those
kind of sites I don't think there's a
particular benefit from doing that and
the key is heritage I'm disappointed to
hear that the developers the applicants
didn't come to a grounding with the
heritage officers and such that the the
harm to heritage still exists that could
have been a solution to this but we
haven't found it I don't think the the
changes they've made is significant
enough to outweigh the harm that's
caught on heritage so I still think
we're kind of back where we were before
which is that it isn't an application
that we should approve so I think the
the harm from this application
particularly does work outweigh the
benefits Thank You councillor Parker you
wanted to come back
yes RHS oricon from about yeah I think
that's a very balanced and very measured
set of comments that the councillor
Busby makes there for me the the
principal issue here for me is the
heritage issues still and I would like
to hear that fleshed out with regards to
councillor Busby's point around need I
have every sympathy for his comments
there and I have every sympathy indeed
for the community
that's broughton because you know I know
I know you know there are a number of
applications that may or may not be
coming forward and we'll have to deal
with each of those as they do or don't
come forward the difficulty for me as a
planning committee is for all the
sympathy that I have with the proposed
amount of development that that might be
coming forward that Broughton we as a
committee are bound by our own planning
rules and indeed the National planning
policy framework and I would have some
serious reservations about how you would
articulate any refusal based upon need
at this time
and as councillors you know we're
elected representatives it's right and
proper that we that we say all the right
things of course and and and that we do
support our communities but how do we
articulate that and indeed if members
were minded to refuse on the basis of
knees we should always bear in mind that
the the reasons that we give based
around the need have got to be
defendable at any any potential you
appeal hearing in the future and I'm
just not convinced that we would be able
to defend on need so for me it's all
about heritage and I would like to have
that conversation fleshed out some more
thank you
officers did you want to come back onto
any of that that you've heard no no no I
don't think there's any particular want
to cancel aplomb thank you chairman
thank you very much I thought about
time I said something I'm very very much
aware of the fact that that I live a
long way from sprouting and then what
happens here will probably affect me at
all but like I have some concerns that
the accumulative effect we're saying on
on infrastructure which I'll take into
consideration because it's a standalone
application but I am very much feeling
that that we are in the situation where
if you go to cs2 as defined he adopted
in August 2014 we're going against that
in terms of this particular one so I
think it's very much a conflict before
strategy seeds cs2 and to me the
Heritage impact far outweighs any public
benefits that we have at all because I
think the comments that were made then
if we do this we these things will that
will be it we will lose the heritage
lookouts the Heritage views of these
particular items and and that to me is
is it not lessons of strength of harm
it is harmed thank you thank you
right Kent's Linton Thank You mr.
chairman
just coming back as we got that screen
of slide 44 up which shows broad
compliance with CS 11 well I've got CS
11 in Perth
open in front of me and it doesn't even
broadly comply with the with a core
village let alone with the hinterland
village and it does also took in there
look says it actually in the CS 11 the
cumulative impact of development within
both the hinterland village in which the
development is proposed and within the
functional cluster of villages which
presumably would includes the walls Lee
Park Woolsey Grange at state in which it
is located will be a material
consideration when assessing such
proposals so I think there are far too
many boxes within CS 11 which come up
with a - rather than a plus
to make it acceptable under CS 11 and
certainly I agree with counsel aplomb
and with others on the the heritage
implication once you destroy the
Heritage then or in terms of views or
whatever then we've destroyed it that's
it thank you did plan mother's want to
come back on that I wouldn't mind just
coming back on one issue about the
community of sheikhs I think there might
be two kind of conversations going on
about that and cumulative issue it is a
consideration as councilman rightly
identifies under CS 11 and it is a
matter that we have looked at in this
application I think there might be some
two different discussions going on where
there's the background say traffic
levels and existing issues within
sportin but we're looking at this
application what traffic does this
application add to that Network in
accumulation with the existing
background traffic levels and with
there's other planning applications that
we've identified in the surrounding area
so it has made a cumulative assessment
with the relevant considerations but
it's just we can't look at the existing
issues I think I just want to make that
separation just the members are aware
that we are considering this cumulative
lis but only within the bounds that we
can not to address all existing issues
is my example earlier said of say if the
a14 shuts and traffic coming through
sport and that's not something that we
can seek to address I hope that
clarifies the matter for members on
cuted issue yes I think we have been
there before I've got two people at the
moment of three another one and cancel a
pass or followed by councillor Ayers
well yeah obviously this is now gonna be
a fast-moving new bike you know I cannot
refer my question and allow councillors
to go first actually Thank You
councillor Ayers
Thank You chair um I just like so do
know the area very well having traveled
the rat run for about 20 years on my way
to various schools but I listened to the
debate and listened to what other people
have to say
interesting that counts and aberrant
said about below a quarter of the people
of surrounding area responded to the
questionnaire but I am looking at more
on the positive side and would done
would go forward to recommend that we
approve right thank you so you're
proposing that we accept the officers
recommendation yes that is correct
at this point that I must ask for a
second before we can continue do I have
a seconder to the proposal put forward
by councilor Suez
I guess mr. chairman cancel our us-born
you have second that did you wish to
comment at this time
[Music]
thank you right no I'll get back to
where we were cantaloupe Parker did you
want to come in though yeah okay I will
do so you've got a proposal on the on
the table now but okay I still maintain
that the predominant issue here is
heritage so I would like to just ask a
question of our officer because there is
there is some conflicting some
contradictory information within the
report and I'm looking particularly at
Heritage's response on page 21 and they
themselves so our heritage team asked
I'm absolutely mindful of the fact that
they don't support this application they
themselves do say that the development
is less harmful to the significance of
the various assets than it was
previously
and yet we have heard lots of common
from from both counselors the speakers
that actually even though nothing has
changed in this application from
previous applications but I would argue
that that actually it has subtly the
layout of the site has sought at least
to go some weight and mitigating some of
the suppose at arm so I'm really you
know without putting the officer on this
but I'm looking for clarification you
know has this changed significantly
enough to warrant members to reconsider
the previous decision I think this is
where your balance and skills has to
come into a counselor Parker but I'll
see if I can get an answer that help us
all Joe or Steven yes yeah I'll take
that one if that's okay chair yes on
page 21 of the committee reports under
the title for Heritage comments on the
original scheme for 54 dwellings I'm
sorry should have care we should have
made it clearer that originally the
scheme was for more dwellings and I
think I didn't have I didn't know I
didn't want to go chapter and verse into
every single iteration of this
application because it would be a very
long report but the Heritage comments on
page 21 saying that the Heritage harm
had reduced from a previous iteration of
the scheme for even more dwellings on
the site and I think it was a scale
issue as well I think potentially there
were lesser single-story dwellings so to
draw back to this application now if we
turn over the page to page 22 the
comments from heritage and the 49
dwellings the level of harm stays the
same
in heritage offices terms between the
scheme for 54 dwellings and 49 dwellings
so apologies the reduction harm was for
an earlier scheme I think I think the
very first submitted scheme with the
planning application which was more
dwellings but just four points of doubt
for the scheme that members looked at
last year at now the Heritage level of
harm remains the same in officers
opinion thank you
councillor plum Thank You chair I think
the proposals draw a bit ahead this
answer return I was going to respond to
the offices
comments about highways when
when someone like myself was talk about
infrastructure which very much taking on
the comments that John who wouldn't and
made in terms of infrastructure is not
only the roads it's the use of those
roads because people may have to drive
to drop the surgeries way outside the
area that they could walk in so I'm just
a little bit concerned that we're not
thinking the film in effect on the
highways but I accept that meantime I
would say we must really really positive
trait on the Heritage things thank you
thank you
right is there any other comments that
members want to make right well it's a
bitter proposal put forward to accept
the author's recommendation proposed by
councillor sue Ayers and it's been
seconded by Councillor Adrienne Osborn
that we accept the officers
recommendations as in our papers so with
that I'm now going to ask Rob Carmichael
to do the roll call and go through the
members to vote Thank You chair and this
is just to confirm this is on the first
application that we are looking at of I
just get the reference number for
clarity sorry
DC 18020 one so I'll take them in order
if you could please respond with four
against four abstain
so councillor sue Aires for Chancellor
Melanie Barrett for councillor Peter
beer for councillor David Busby
against counselor John Hinton against
Casserly Jamison against customary
McLaren against cancer Adrian Osbourne
for cats Alison Owen against
Casserly Parker against Casa Steven plum
okay Thank You commanders the devotion
is lost
okay thank you very much just as legal
that that I couched as well indeed
certain votes to forces lost yep that's
what I've got as well thank you very
much right so now I need to ask you you
wish to go forward no but we need
another motion put forward by those that
voted against
Chancellor Busbee thank you
well I think it's against heritage I
think the impact on heritage I'm not
good with numbers and policies but I
think the Heritage impact is still too
great and I think the in the conclusions
you mentioned core strategy cs2 and I'm
not convinced about CSE eleven being in
broad compliance either that was the
house and survey yep offices is that
acceptable
um yes mother works just coming in here
paper clubs you can sit there and
because we're obviously staring down an
overturn here and I think it's really
important that we just start to
articulate the key issues in order that
we can formulate them any leavings for
abusal you have to obviously there is a
breach of fear - I think that's
acknowledged in the officer report
that's going obviously there is that
that practice it is in the countryside
and presumably members are saying there
are no exceptional circumstances and and
certainly the need for this development
isn't justifiable in light of the harm I
think just on the broadest air celebrity
quant and I was I would be cautious
about saying that there wasn't
necessarily a locally identified need I
think we saw that play out in the long
melted inquiry and obviously you have
the decision from the Secretary of State
on that only a few weeks ago I think
it's going to be very difficult
certainly in the absence of any clear
directions for the contrary from members
on this but there isn't a need and
probably Offices of suggested that
whilst it's slightly scamp but there is
a pointing to there being a need people
fill body development to to read look at
that see s11
but if you like to carry around the
other issues heritage okay yeah and then
actually from my own do I think this
ultimately is a heritage case and I
think obviously members have made a
number of comments now about heritage I
think in respect of that what would be
really
is to understand first inform at how
harmful it is and whether this is there
following the offices conclusion that is
a medium level of lessen substantial
harm and more importantly they did is
lessen substantial harm that doesn't
mean as I said previously that the harm
is lessen significant is just in MCPS
parlance it just affects the way that
you deal with that harm and obviously
you do attach a considerable importance
to it and I think as a number of members
have said that the harm would would be
knocked out weighed by the public
benefit and in doing so it be also
really useful to understand which assets
themselves are being harmed by the or
would be harmed by this opponent and I
think Barry's be self about in the
officer report and indeed the previous
resolution of this committee which not
meaning to influence members were just
pointing out as a matter of fact they
were sporting Hall root Farm tithe barn
and the greatest are lifted all thank
you
councillor Busby you've heard all that I
think the cs2 Housing Survey the feeling
is that perhaps that wouldn't be
sensible to pursue that one but you
could elaborate on the heritage medium
to harm and that could carry weight with
cs2 I think we take the office the
Heritage offices comments on that I
think yep he's exactly right on that I
take the jobs with the housing need the
only housing need survey was conducted
before Woolsey Grange has been built out
I think if they conducted a housing
needs survey now which is when we're
actually doing the decision I'm not so
certain that there would be shown from
Broughton residents that the would be a
housing need and I think yet the other
points that I would water be this is
outside the village boundary therefore
it has to show you know a much greater
positive benefit than
boom harm Plus this is also the harm to
the SAS a lake well cancel officers
I think cancel sorry officers I think
counselor Busby has made a case for keep
and CS 11,000 survey in in his
recommendation for refusal her do you
want to comment on that data
you've got the we could be looking at as
an opening for the reasons for google
then the circumstances of the
application and the proposed development
are not exceptional and without the
proven justifiable need contrary to
policy fear to in CS 11 mm-hmm would be
acceptable counselor Busby yeah it
sounds good thank you Steve and sorry
okay and and then moving on to the
Heritage before I did I just
on the Fla point again this is something
that is covered in in the officer report
and and obviously there will always be
an element of harm for the development
of the green fields rice that in
landscape terms obviously this is not
necessarily representative at the whole
of the special landscape areas and I
think from the report noted it's a
relatively enclosed site and I think we
might be hard-pressed to and defend a
discrete and independent landscape
reason for a fuse or bit again I've put
that to councillor Busby and if you
wants to press that point that obviously
we can we can keep it but I think
certainly that the Heritage point yes I
mean I agree I think we're already
looking at small elements that still
contrary and provide harm the biggest
one obviously is heritage so out of a
hundred you'd probably apply 80 points
to the Heritage but there are other
factors which cumulative Lee add up to
saying that the harm is greater than the
benefit
right thank you I've got canceller
Jemison followed by councillor Hinton so
I'll just take councillor Jamison
Jamison some point does cro4 not come
into play as well because to the SLA
cancel it Jamison well I was just
thinking um from get maintain enhance a
special landscape area qualities of the
area well this doesn't really do that
and in line and we've also the Heritage
aspect I wondered if it may be a was
they could be taken into account
Stephen CRI for is from yeah it's a safe
policy from from the old local plan at
2006 it is relevant clearly and
respected special land areas and that's
right the policy text does require
maintenance all in harms of the areas
that I've made the point in if this is a
an element of the reasons refusal to be
put forward I think you need to be clear
you know why they know why it would be
contrary about particular policy and why
any mitigating measures of the design of
the theme don't necessarily deal with
that point right thank you
cancel the Busby do you want to accept
cro4 and if you do to elaborate on it I
have says I think it's the objection
strong enough without er reform it just
makes a point
thank you then I've got councillor
Hinton would you like to come in now
councillor Hinton yeah sorry
just get into the right right button to
press yes I would like to second
councillor Busby's proposal and can I
suggest that when you're looking at the
final sorry
summary which is slide 44 it's in
conflict with the call strategy cs2
Brod it says broad compliance on this
and I would have to say that is in broad
conflict with CS 11 and CS 15 points in
CS 11 are against this site but more are
against it than are in favor of it so
the balance of acceptance or harm if you
like to call it that in planning terms
is against this proposal using both CS f
FN and CS 15 thank you
yes co-chairs just to say that yes
obviously we will import them a planning
balance into this final resolution from
four members to offer the proposer to
consider because opposite it's not just
a case of chucking some reasons for
refusal I think bearing in mind this is
a neighbor term we need to be very clear
about the reasons and follow-through
kind of the general approach to planning
balance I'm just wondering if I if I
might just have two minutes just to
knock something together and then and
then come back with some words because
Hidde and then I'll ask him and the
second I want to accept that yeah that
would be fight cool down councillor
Parker's got something to say I think
Chancellor parkour we can take that
while he's doing that